hey everyone welcome to this tutorial
where we're going to start with a brand
new android project
and see it all the way through to
publishing on google play
my name is rahul and i'm a software
engineer and youtuber who loves teaching
i think the best way to learn something
is to build things and so we're going to
build
a memory game app to learn android
development with kotlin
as you go through this if you have any
questions or feedback i'd love to
connect with you
i'm at rponde1234 on youtube and twitter
the memory game is the perfect way to
cover a lot of core android concepts
we'll talk about dynamic layouts
multiple screens
image loading and persistence with
firebase
along the way i'll share some practical
tips and tricks about app development
and my checklist that i always go
through before publishing any app onto
google play
i'm going to assume you have some
programming experience
and if you have a basic familiarity with
android that's an added bonus
we're going to be using a programming
language called kotlin which is now the
recommended way to develop android apps
you're welcome to follow along if you're
new to kotlin or even if you're new to
programming
but i'd recommend that you go through a
quick kotlin intro first
once you're done building the app share
it on social media with the hashtag
mymemory and don't forget to tag me so i
can check it out as well
let me do a quick demo of the memory app
that we're going to build
this game is really popular i played it
a lot growing up and i'm sure
it's familiar for many of you the
objective is to try and find pairs with
matching images
so here i have two cards which don't
match when i flip over a third card
then the other two will flip back down
and the reason this is called memory is
because
once you've identified where a image is
you have to use your memory or
concentration to find out where have you
previously seen that
card so here i know the matching flower
image is over there
and now i can continue until i have
found all of the pairs
once i found all the pairs in the game
then the confetti falls and i have that
message and we can also see
information about the game at the bottom
of the screen
in the menu i can tap this button to
restart the game and that shows me new
random images and i can also choose a
different size
memory board so right now we're showing
an eight card game which is
four pairs and i can make it a little
bit harder by choosing the hard version
which is
24 cards and so now you can see how we
are dynamically changing the size of
each memory card in order to
fill up the phone width and height
one other thing we can do is download a
custom game so this is a really cool
part of the game
it is that anyone in the world can
create their own memory game with photos
from their phone
and we can actually play that so for
example i created a
custom memory game called bitmoji
so bitmoji is my bitmoji character my
cartoon doing different activities and
so now
if you flip over a card you can see
these are images from my phone that i
uploaded into a custom memory game and
we can play the game like normal where
we're trying to match up images
and finally of course you can also
create your own custom
memory game so i'm going to choose to
create an easy game which means i have
to upload four images
this will now launch the existing
gallery app on your phone
and i can select photos from my phone so
i have these
very adorable photos of corgis i want to
give this game name
the name of corgi and tap save and what
this is doing is it's
persisting these images to firebase and
once that's done now we can actually
play our custom game
so you can see the images of the core
keys that we have here
and the cool thing is now i can share
this game name corgi with anyone in the
world and they can play the same game
so there's a lot of really cool concepts
i want to cover in the process of
building this
and i'm really excited to get started
with you i'm going to make it really
easy for you to follow along with me
which means i'm going to keep copy paste
to a minimum and the only tools that you
really need
are android studio and a working
emulator or
a phone an android phone i'll also leave
a link in the description to the github
repository which contains all the code
so you can
feel free to reference that as well
here's a picture cloud representation of
the main concepts we'll be covering so
first off we're going to become
very familiar with android studio we're
also going to be talking about
vector icons so android studio will help
us to create a bunch of these
vector images that will be used as a
default memory game
images we'll also talk about views and
measuring out
how much space to allocate with the
content the padding and the margin which
lives outside the view
all that content will live largely
inside of a recycler view which is how
we're displaying
the grid of memory cards so recyclerview
is a very core component
in android and we'll talk about the
different parts that make up a
recyclerview
we're also going to be dealing with two
firebase services the first is cloud
storage which is what will be storing
our images
second is cloud firestore which will be
the database associating our game name
to a list of image urls then finally
we're going to
spend a bit of time talking about how do
we create a release app
that we can then publish onto google
play and also talk about how to optimize
your google play store listing
i'll leave a link to the published app
in the google play store in the
description so you can
in the download segment we are going to
construct the layout for the main screen
or main ui
for our application just one more thing
i wanted to say a big thank you to free
codecamp for building out an amazing
platform to reach
so many students subscribe to their
channel and check out my channel if you
want more content like this
we're going to get started by creating a
brand new android studio project
and then the goal for this segment is to
set up the scaffolding for the main
layout or main
ui for our memory game here's what the
final user interface for our app will
look like
at the top we have an action bar which
comes in by default
in every internet app and it describes
how the user can navigate through your
app
the bulk of the screen will be taken up
by something called a recycler view and
that's how
we're going to power this grid of memory
cards
that make up our memory game at the
bottom we have
two labels or two text views that
describe the current state of the game
and so at the end of this part here's
what our ui will look like at the top we
have the default action bar
at the bottom we have a horizontal
linear layout with
two text views with dummy data and the
rest of the screen will be filled up
with an empty recycler view
let's open up android studio and you can
see here that i'm running version 4.1
any recent version of android studio
should do so i'm going to
tap the option for creating a new
project and let's go ahead and pick the
empty activity template
tap on next and we're going to call this
project my memory
because it's a customizable memory game
the package name has to be a unique
identifier for your app and it will
dictate the directory structure for your
project
typically i'll take my domain name
rkpuna.com or my email address and flip
it backward
pick a location for where you want to
save it we're going to pick the language
of kotlin which is the more modern and
recommended
way of building android apps going
forward the minimum sdk i'm going to
pick
api level 21 which is android 5.0
otherwise known as lollipop and you can
see here
android studio is telling us that if we
pick api 21
that means our app will run on 94
percent of devices
so that means around six percent of
android devices are running a version of
android which is more than five years
old and they won't be able to download
our app
but there's a lot of pain associated
with actually
back porting your app and making sure it
runs on all these super old
android os so i would recommend that you
stick with api 21.
let's tap on finish and then android
studio initially when it creates your
project it will
actually try building it based on the
scaffolding that you picked so we have
empty activity which means that
we just have a kind of a blank activity
here which will say hello world
and the very first thing i like to do
whenever i create a brand new project is
simply to run it and running it will
give me the confidence that i haven't
screwed anything up in the setup i have
android studio set up properly i have an
emulator set up properly
and i'm actually able to compile and run
my app
i have a bunch of emulators already set
up here if you don't have
any emulators click on avd manager it's
android virtual device manager and that
will guide you through the process of
creating a new
emulator that you can install the app on
i'm going to go with this pixel 2 api
29 emulator and without making any code
changes
i'm simply going to hit this green
triangle in order to run the app
and boot up the emulator in the process
awesome so you can see down here at the
bottom how it says the operation
succeeded
and just like we want we're able to see
this default empty
application which says hello world so
let me quickly talk through what we get
in the starter project here there are
really two files that you should be
concerned about
one is the main activity.kotlin file the
dot kt means it's a kotlin file
in the world of android you can think of
an activity like one screen in your
application
so this file main activity.kotlin will
be
where we write the core logic for the
memory game it'll be the brain of our
app
and the critical line here is set
contentview
r.layout.activitymain so what this is
referring to is that there is a
resource file called activity main so r
stands for resource
and r.layout means look inside of the
layout directory
of the resources and look for a file
called activity main
so we can actually try doing that my
preference is to select the
android view of our project the initial
perspective which is
simply called project represents the
actual file hierarchy
of the project on disk but it's a little
harder to navigate
and the android view is how i
conceptually think about my project
so instead of the android view in the
app directory there's a folder here
called dress which is short for
resources so like we talked about
there's a layout directory
inside of res let's check that and
there's one file here called
activitymain.xml and that's what is
creating a link between the main
activity
and the underlying ui or layout
so i can go to the definition of
activity main by hitting
ctrl b or command b
and that will jump to this other file
activity main in android we define
layouts using xml a markup language
which
allows us to define the views on the
screen their position
and how they're structured with one
another so you can have views
inside of another view and you can see
here how it's really simple right now
all it is is a constraint layout as the
root element and inside there's a text
view
which just says hello world and that is
how we are
seeing the hello world text when we ran
our application
now we can start making changes and i
want to be really precise about what
we're going to do
in this segment which is i just want to
add a bottom component which will
describe
info about the current game being played
in particular there'll be two text views
one for the number of moves on the left
and one on the right side showing how
many pairs have been matched
so that means we're going to have to be
modifying the activity main.xml
and you'll notice here that there are
three different perspectives of this
xml file so we have the code which is
basically the underlying xml
representation
split which is both and then design
which is just looking at the
preview rendered in android studio
itself
so to give us give ourselves a bit more
space i'm going to double tap on
activity main and that basically
minimized
this project tool window and the first
thing i want to do is get rid of the
default hello world and we are now going
to drag out a
linear layout which is horizontal
orientation because these are going to
be
right and left the two texts at the
bottom are going to be horizontally
aligned
and we are going to set the layout width
to be match constraint which means that
we're going to have
the width be dictated by the constraints
that means that we should add some
constraints
so from the left end of the screen i
want it to be zero dp
which means i just wanted to be flush
with the left end and same thing on the
right
and essentially what that did is it's
making the width of this linear layout
the whole screen width
we also want to constrain the bottom of
this linear layout to the bottom of the
screen
so add 0 down here as well i also want
to
change the height of this to be wrap
content
which basically means i want the linear
layout to only have as much height as
whatever is inside of it
inside of linear layout we are going to
contain two elements
and these are going to be card views and
the card views are actually what
will contain the text view so card views
are a really nice android component
which show some elevation so it's a
material design
recommended ui so that's what we'll use
to create some separation between the
text views and we'll actually also use
it for each memory card
so i have a card view here i'm going to
change the corner radius to be 8 dp here
and then inside of the card view i want
to drag out a
text view so a couple changes i want to
make here
first off i want to make the width and
height to be match parent
so this texture takes up the whole width
and height of the parent which is the
card view
i want to make the text appearance large
make it a little bit bigger
let's also give it some dummy text here
so this is this one is going to
represent the number of moves that the
user has done so we'll start out with
zero moves and then i'd like to add some
padding onto this text view
so let me search for this attribute
called padding
and let's give give this textview a
padding of 8dp
all around so you can see how it created
some space let me zoom in on the design
preview just so we can get a closer look
at
the changes we're making the last thing
on this textview is i want to set the
gravity of it to be center
which basically means out of all the
space that we have i want to be
centered inside of the card view so
search for gravity
and then we are going to set the gravity
to be center
you can see how it got centered in there
now going back to the card view one
thing i want to add
onto the card view is a margin so we can
see
a separation between the card view and
the background which is the linear
layout
so search for margin and we are going to
add a margin of
10 dp on all sides
so now you can start to actually see
this card you take shape and have
this elevation that i mentioned earlier
we actually want two different card
views on the bottom in the linear layout
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go over here
copy this then go and select the linear
layout and then paste it
what we did here is we are embedding two
card views in the linear layout
and in order to make them show up side
by side there's a property on the
elements in the linear layout called
weight and the weight
dictates how much space should the
linear layout allocate for this child
so if we set the value to be equal on
each of the
card views that basically means we want
an equal amount of space allocated
that looks good so now in the text here
on the right
we don't want that to represent the
number of moves we want that to
represent
how many pairs have been found i'll call
this
pairs and then we'll say zero out of
four all right and then you can see how
one
issue that we have right now is that the
id of these textures is identical so
let's go back into the code tab now and
fix this
so you can see again here in the code
tab the red
error highlighting and one thing to keep
in mind also is that any change that you
make in the design tab
there's a one to one correspondence
between that and what you see in the
code tab so you can kind of see here
we have a linear layout and inside that
linear layout is a card view
with the text view inside and then the
same thing down here so we would like to
change the id
of this one to be tv
num moves because it represents a text
view with number of moves
and then the id of this one should be tv
num
pairs the one more thing i want to do
while we're
in the code section is i would like to
add a background color on the linear
layout
i'm just going to add the background
attribute and the
value of this i would we wanted to set
to attribute
and there's one inbuilt called color
secondary variant which is
kind of this teal color and if we go in
the design tab you can see
what that looks like cool that looks
pretty good so now if you're on the app
we should no longer be seeing the hello
world text and we should now be seeing
this linear layout at the bottom with
that hard-coded text that we have
awesome next we're going to drag out a
recyclerview and this is going to be the
primary component which will hold on to
all the cards in our memory game
and i want to set the left and right
constraints of this to be 0 dp so i want
to take up the whole screen with
the top constraint should be flushing at
the top of the screen and the bottom
constraint i want this to be
actually up against the top of the
linear layer at the bottom in order to
have that take a visible effect we need
to change
the layout height to be zero dp and now
you can see how the recyclerview is
basically taking up
all the remaining space after we've
allocated the space for
the linear layout at the bottom of the
screen and also the
layout width we can also make it match
constraint zero dp
because we've properly defined the the
constraints
on the left and right side
and this recyclerview won't have any
visible ui change because we haven't
actually written the logic to populate
it yet
that's what we'll do in the next part
the last thing i want to do
to wrap up this part though is go back
to main activity and let's actually grab
references
to each of the views that we have on the
screen now so in particular i would like
to be able to get references to
any of the components that we have that
we will need to change programmatically
so in particular these two text views
and the recycler view so give this an id
name of rv board
because it represents our memory board
tap on refactor
tv num moves looks good tv numpair looks
good and i'll just let's just go ahead
and change the default name of the id
here of linear layout 2 and make this
ll game info which stands for linear
layout game info this is a container
with all of the information of the game
and then let's refactor
and android studio will take care of
updating anywhere else that this id is
referenced
so now in mainactivity the pattern here
is any
widget that we have in our layout we can
reference in mainactivity and we'll
define that as a
private member variable and all these
will be private late in it var
so for example rv board and this is
going to be of type recyclerview
and then similarly we're going to have
one for tv
num moves this is going to be a text
view
and there's going to be one more which
is tv numpairs
and that's also a textview and the
reason it's a late init var
is because we know that these variables
will be set
but they'll be set in the oncreate
method which is invoked by the android
system they're not going to be created
at the time of construction of the main
activity and that's why this is a late
in it
late initialization so now in the on
create as soon as we've called set
content view
now we can set these newly defined
variables equal to
the corresponding view in the layout and
we'll do that by calling a special
method
find view by id and provide the id that
we assigned
so for the recyclerview we give it an id
of rv board
and similarly tv num moves
and then finally tv num pair
[Music]
now we've set up the scaffolding for the
main activity and we have references
to the key views on the layout the goal
the next part is to
add in data to the recycler view in a
4x2 grid
of memory cards that we'll define so we
have now
this linear layout at the bottom which
shows information about the current game
and we have this empty recycler view
which takes up all the remaining space
our goal for this part is to fill up
that recycler view with a grid of icons
which will
which will eventually be each memory
card that you can tap on and flip over
but for now we're just going to put in
some dummy icon and the interesting
thing here
is that the size of each of these cards
that you're seeing
are not hard-coded instead we're going
to dynamically
set the width and height according to
how much
space we have so on a larger phone or on
a tablet these will appear bigger
on a smaller phone we're going to reduce
the size appropriately
we're going to make them just large
enough that we can fill up the entire
space
that we're given in this recyclerview
so jumping back into the code every
recyclerview has
two core components one is the adapter
and one is the layout manager
given some views that should be shown in
the recyclerview the layout manager is
responsible for measuring and
positioning those items
so the layout manager is actually quite
simple for us
we're going to use a predefined layout
manager that comes with android called
the grid layout manager
and this is how we're going to have this
nice grid effect
so this takes in two parameters one
which is a context so we're passing in
this which is referencing the main
activity
because the main activity is an example
of a context and a second parameter here
is the span count otherwise known as how
many columns
are in your recycler view so for now
we're going to hard code this four by
two grid so there's going to be two
columns
and each column was going to have four
rows we're going to pass in two here and
then later on we're going to have to
make this dynamic
based on what the user has picked the
other component
that we're going to define for the
recycler view
is an adapter the adapter is more
involved than the layout manager because
it's responsible for taking in
the underlying data set of the recycler
view and turning that into
or adapting each piece of data into a
view
i'm going to set this adapter property
on the recycler view and we're going to
define a new class
which has all the logic for the adapter
called memory board
adapter and this will take in two
parameters one which is the context
so i'm going to pass in this and second
will be how many elements
total are in our grid and we're gonna
hard code this in
as eight for now and we'll change that
later on
before we define this memory board
adapter there's one more thing
that i want to point out which is
optional but it's a performance
optimization
which is that there's a method on the
recycler view called
set has fixed size and we're going to
pass in true here
and what this method does if you look at
the documentation
is that we know the size of the recycler
view is not affected by the adapter
contents
so like we talked about earlier the size
of the recycler view on the screen is
always going to be defined as soon as
the app boots up and it won't change
regardless of how many memory cards are
inside the recycler view
and so by setting has fixed size to be
true
we can make our application a bit more
efficient
okay so now let's go back and you can
see how under studio is complaining that
this
class isn't defined so let's have inner
studio help us to define
this class so tap on the red light bulb
and tap on create class memory board
adapter
and we're going to extract this out into
a separate file in the same package name
okay so the first parameter is going to
actually be a context
not an activity and the second
constructor parameter will be num pieces
representing how many memory cards there
are and that will be an integer
then hit tab one more time one thing i
want to do is i want to prefix each of
these
constructor parameters with private val
and that will actually allow us to
use this in the body of our class what
we have here
is a class memory board adapter which is
a subclass
of the recyclerviewadapter class you'll
notice that this is parametrized
by something called
recyclerview.viewholder
so a viewholder is an object which
provides access to
all the views of one recyclerview
element and so
in our case that will represent one
memory piece or one memory card in the
game
and we're going to define our own view
holder which will encapsulate
that memory card view and so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to actually
define an inner class here
called viewholder and this is going to
inherit from the recyclerview view
holder
[Music]
hit this red lightbulb and then we need
to match the constructor invocation of
the view holder
and now that we've defined this view
holder instead of being parameterized by
the
base class i want to be parametrized by
this inner class that we just defined
so we'll need to import that
okay and now that we've defined the
inner class and we're parameterized by
that
now hit this red light bulb that android
studio is complaining about for the
memory board adapter and implement the
numbers
the recyclerview adapter class is an
abstract class which means that we have
several methods that we need to override
in order for it to function and there
are three that we need to override i'm
going to select all three and tap on ok
and my preference is to have the inner
class show up at the bottom of the class
so i'm going to have that i'm going to
move that down here
and now there are three methods here
oncreateviewholder is responsible for
figuring out how to create one view of
our
recyclerview getitemcount is actually
really easy so i'm going to define that
right now which is how many elements are
in our recycler view and that will
simply be
the constructor parameter that we passed
in num pieces
and then onbindviewholder is responsible
for
taking the data which is at this
position and
binding it to this view holder which is
passed in here
so we'll we'll come to that in a little
bit but first let's define
the oncreateviewholder method so the
pattern here typically is we're going to
use a layout inflator i'm going to
create it from the context which is the
parameter that we passed in the
constructor
and we're going to inflate a resource
file which defines our layout
with the r.layout.memory underscore card
and this takes in two more parameters
one which is the view group the root
view group and that'll be the parent
which is the perimeter passed in
and then the third parameter is attached
to root we're going to pass in false
here
we have to now define this layout file
again android video will help us with
this create
layout resource file have the root
element of this be a linear layout
tap on ok the objective here is to add
in some children elements on this linear
layout such that we create
the view for one individual memory card
in our game
so if i go into the design tab what
we'll do is
first off let's change the height of
this linear layout to be
wrap content let's drag in a card view
and inside the card view will be an
image button
we'll drag out an image button and let's
have the
underlying drawable or icon behind that
image button be this icy launcher
background which is a screen grid you
should have that already from the
default android studio project
tap on ok let's have the id simply be
image button
and have the width and height be match
parent
now you can see how it takes up the full
dimensions of the
card view which is apparent let's set
the background to be white
this is a solid white color and the
scale type can be center crop
well and the card view represents one
actual
memory card so there's a couple design
tweaks i want to do here first off
i want to hard code the width and height
to be 120 dp
just to give it a more realistic feel of
what a memory card might actually look
like
but we're going to change this to be
dynamically measured later on
but for now 120 is a pretty good default
let's change the card corner radius and
height to be 8 dp
so it stands out a bit more
and let's also give this an id of card
view
finally the last thing i want to do is
set the gravity of this parent linear
layout to be centered so this card view
goes into the center of the screen
so search for gravity and then
hit center
all right awesome so you can see how
we're now aligned to the center of the
screen
so going back into the memory board
adapter now this error went away
and the return value of layout inflator
inflate will be the actual view
which was created i'll say valve view
and then what we want to return here is
the view wrapped inside of a view holder
and then in on bind view holder what i
want to do
is for now just called holder dot bind
[Music]
position and bind to something which is
not yet defined because
energy is looking for this method to be
defined on the viewholder class it
doesn't exist yet so industry will help
us to create it
and for now this is going to be a no-op
and then later on
we'll come back and address this okay
let's run the app
and see what happens
awesome so what you can see here is we
are now
getting eight different elements in our
recyclerview
in this grid four by two grid and you
can kind of see the outlines of the
different cards that we've laid out
so what you can see here is that we're
not really making a good use of all the
space that we've allocated for the
recyclerview right like we have this
kind of awkward white space at the
bottom and also we want to ideally have
some margin between each of the memory
cards in our
recycler view so let's figure out how to
do that
the first thing that's worth pointing
out is that the space allocated for each
memory card
will depend on how many memory cards we
have so right now we have this
four by two grid which means we have two
cards across and
four cards tall on the other hand if we
have
a slightly larger board where we have
three cards across and four cards tall
now we have 12 cards instead of eight
that means that the amount of width
allocated for each memory card is going
to shrink
so let's implement that first going back
into the code
we need to measure what is the width and
height of the
recycler view which is containing all
the memory cards and based on that
change the width of our card view so
instead of having this be hard-coded to
be 120 dp
we want to measure that according to the
recyclerview width and height
and that turns out not to be that
difficult because the recyclerview is
actually the parent which is passed in
here
so if we wanted to figure out what is
the
width of the card so i'll say val card
width
then that will be the parent dot the
width
divided by however many columns we have
in our grid so in this example because
we're hard coding is four by two
grid the width will be divided by two
and then similarly for the card height
we have four cards tall so we're going
to
divide the height of the recycler view
by four
and we're going to mandate that each
memory card in our game is going to be
square
so we're going to take the smaller of
the card with a card height
so i'll call it card side length
that's going to be the minimum of card
width
and card height and you might have to
import min which is coming from
kotlin.math.min at the top here
so now we need to actually grab out the
card view
from the view that we've inflated and
set the width and height of that card
view to be card side length
the way we do that is we say view dot
find view by id
pull out the card view which we gave it
an id of card view
and we're going to get a reference to
the layout params
and this is going to be equal to layout
params
a variable that we defined and on these
layout param this is what will allow us
to change the width and height
the width will be card side length and
the height
will also be card side length so let's
try this one more time
and hopefully now we shouldn't have this
awkward white space at the bottom
and you can see that that is fixed right
so
we are actually taking up the whole
screen width and screen height
there's one more observation i want to
make which is that we don't actually
want
the card to take up the full dimensions
of the space we allocate to it
so for example if we're putting a memory
card into this yellow square
[Music]
we want to have some margin between the
actual icon
and the space around it and the reason
we want that is because if there's a
neighboring card we want
to have some white space in between the
two
[Music]
and so that's the next thing i want to
implement with you which is how do we
add some margin
so that we're not always flush with the
card next to us and this also turns out
not to be that difficult we're going to
define a constant
which is the margin size i'm going to
define that in a companion object
in kotlin companion objects are
singletons where we'll define constants
we can access its members directly
through the containing class
think of companion objects similar to
static variables in java
let's define a constant called margin
size and i'll set that equal to 10
that's what i found to be a reasonable
distance between each memory card
so the card width we actually want it to
be reduced
by the amount of margin on either side
to the right and left and so i'm going
to subtract
2 times the margin size and similarly we
want to reduce the maximum allowable
card height by the margin on the top
and bottom so we'll subtract two times
the margin size again
now we're measuring the dimensions of
the card taking into account the margin
but we actually need to set it
when we grab the card view reference
from the view
we have to cast the layout params as a
special type of layout params called
margin layout params
and once we've done that now we should
be able to
set the margin on the layout params so
let's say set margins and we're going to
set the margin size all around
on all four sides let's try it
that's so much better now we have this
nice white space margin between each
memory card
one quick improvement i'd like to make
here is adding some margin on the
recycler view as a whole at the top and
bottom so going back into activity main
i'm going to add a 8 dp margin to the
top and bottom
and let's just see if that looks a
little bit better now
great i like that a lot more because it
gives us some breathing room between the
memory cards and the underlying parent
view
right now when i tap on any of these
elements nothing actually happens to
wrap up this segment i would like to
actually register a click listener on
each image button which is what these
are so going back into
the memory board adapter inside of the
view holder when we bind the view holder
we're going to
grab a reference to the image button
which is inside that card view
so the way we can do this is in the
constructor of the view holder
i'm going to define the image button
[Music]
the id we gave it was image button
and so here we want to actually set the
image button click listener
[Music]
i'm going to add a log statement here
click
on position and then let's
print out the position so we need to
define this tag which we'll do in the
companion object
and the convention that i use is the tag
name is always the class name
so in this case the class name is memory
board adapter
and let's try this one more time so
we're going to run the application and
also open up logcat
so i am going to filter out only for
info level logs because we actually have
this at info level
and i'm also going to look for logs from
memory board adapter so i started typing
in memory
and now if we tap on an element you can
see okay we do see click on position
zero if i go down here
that's position two position four and
this last one is position seven which
makes sense
because we have eight cards from
position zero to position seven
just one more thing before before we
wrap up this segment if you
notice if we go to the ends of the
recycler view and scroll up or down we
get these
shadows which are the material design
way of
indicating that we're at the end of this
recycler view there's no more content
in our app it doesn't really make that
much sense because we are mandating or
guaranteeing
that the content of the recyclerview
will be fit
to the screen dimension because the
content is never scrollable we should
never be seeing this visual indicator
called edge effect
and so if we go back into activity main
and then go into the recycler view
and then search for this attribute
called over scroll mode
and set that to never that should
address that issue so if we
rerun the app now
when i scroll up or down you can see
that there is no shadow
the goal for the next part is to
introduce the notion of a board size so
we don't have to keep hard coding in a
4x2 grid
and we'll create some icons that the
user will eventually pair up as part of
the memory game
now we have this hard-coded 4x2 grid of
8 memory cards
the first thing i want to do in this
segment is create some flexibility so we
can
easily increase or decrease the number
of memory cards in our game
and the second thing i want to do is
create a bunch of vector icons
which will be used as the default icons
when we play a new memory game
so first off in order to build in more
flexibility into the dimensions of our
memory game
there's a couple things we need to
adjust so first off right now
we are passing in two and four here as
the dimensions of the board which is
incorrect
that'll change depending on how many
cards are in a memory game
and second we also are passing in two
here for the span count which is how
many columns are in our board and that
also might change
so in order to encode all the different
information about the size of the board
i'm actually going to create an enum
called board size and so if you open up
the directory where main activity is
located i'm going to create a new
package here
a new package called models and we're
going to add to this
later on with a couple other things but
for now the only thing this will have
is a
kotlin file called board size
and this is going to be an enum and an
enum can optionally take in
a value and so we're going to pass in a
vowel here called num cards this is
going to be an int
so in our current example what we have
now num cards would be eight
because four by two we're going to have
three different values of board size
first is easy
second is medium and that'll be 18 cards
and then lastly is hard which is 24
cards
and these are the different options for
the memory game
so the current version that we're
playing is easy there's only eight cards
medium is 18 and
hard is 24. we also want to encode
in this enum information about the width
and height
corresponding to each board and so i'm
going to define a
couple other methods here one is called
get with
it's going to return int and depending
on the value of the enum
i would like to be able to figure out
what is the width
of the game and so the way we can do
this is say
return using the when construct
this is referring to the board size on
which we're operating easy medium or
hard
and the one expression is similar to a
switch statement so it'll evaluate a
list of conditions and it'll return when
the first one is met
so we're going to have android studio
help us to create all the remaining
branches and what that did
is create a branch for each of the three
enum values
and so in the case of easy the number of
cards
width-wise is going to be two in the
medium case we're gonna have a six by
three
board so we'll have three cards by and
in the hard case we're gonna have four
cards wide they'll be six by four
we're also going to have one method here
which is get height
and one thing to observe is that the
height is fully determined
once we know the number of cards and the
width
right and so the value here is simply
going to be
the number of cards divided by get with
[Music]
and finally there's one more method i
want to
add in here called get num pair
is also going to return in and this
method is going to represent
how many pairs of cards are there right
so if we have
eight memory cards in our game that
means we're gonna have four unique pairs
and so this is simply going to be the
number of cards divided by
two okay awesome
so now back in main activity instead of
hard coding in eight
let's define a variable up here called
private var board size
this is of type of our enum that we
defined
and initially the value is going to be
board size dot easy
and i would like the memory board
adapter to take in the board size
instead of the number of pieces and then
the grid layout manager
the second parameter is how many columns
are there and that'll simply be
board size dot get width
now let's fix up the adapter and the
second parameter should be
of type board size instead of the int so
i'm going to tap this rear light bulb
and change the parameter
to the board size so going back into
memory board adapter
let's change the variable name to
reflect that
and now that we have this we can
update get item count to be board size
dot num cards that's the total number of
elements in our memory game and the
final thing we need to do is update what
we're dividing
the width and height by and this is
going to be the width divided by
the board size get width and the height
we're going to divide by
how many elements tall is our board
let's try it from the ui perspective
this should be identical
and you can see it is but the benefit of
what we did what we did
is we can now very easily adjust the
size of the board for example making it
hard
and now we should expect to see a 6x4
grid instead of a 4x2 and you can see
that that actually happened
and the dimensions and spacing of these
memory cards is looking good
awesome so the next thing i want to do
in this segment is create
icons which will be the actual
underlying image for each of these cards
and this luckily turns out to be really
easy because android studio has a really
nice way to do this
open up the res directory which stands
for resources and right click on
drawable
and go to new and tap on vector asset if
you look at clipart here
android studio comes bundled in with all
of these
free open source icons that we can use
and this is what we're going to be using
to power the default version of our
memory game
so for example why don't we start by
creating one icon which is the face
so just search for face and we have this
nice clip art
and i want to change the color of this
to be red
so red is 255 255.00
choose that and then let's also rename
this to be icyface
tap on next and then this is just
telling us that
it'll be located inside of the drawable
directory ic underscore face and tap on
finish
let's peek inside the created file and
one of the things that amazed me
when i first learned about vector
graphics is that the file is simply
xml data which describes the set of
points
lines and curves along with associated
color information so the image that
we're seeing on the right is completely
described by the text in the xml file
and so the really nice thing about these
vector assets is that they're much much
smaller
compared to a jpeg or png file where you
have to encode information about all
these different pixels and there could
be
thousands of pixels in your image and
the other nice thing about this is that
these are infinitely scalable so because
we're just defining the path data here
whether the image is a hundred by a
hundred or a thousand by a thousand
this image will always be crystal clear
so that's a really nice
thing about these vector assets and so
if we look back to the board size
the maximum size of our board is 24
and that means we need to create 12
unique icons for our memory game
so right now we have one we're going to
create 11 more so let me explain
the logic behind how i created the
vector icons and you can do something
similar
so you're free to choose whatever icons
you want in order to build your memory
game
but i did some thinking about it and
there are two things that we would like
to optimize
for as we pick our icons one is that the
icons the vector icons that we create
should be distinct shapes
and second they should be distinct
colors and the idea here is that
when you're playing memory you want to
have each unique image be as
distinct as possible the shapes will
come simply because we're choosing
different icons
the colors are a bit more interesting so
as we think about
what colors to make our icons each color
is represented as a red
green blue component and each of these
three components
is an integer between 0 and 255. if you
wanted to create
as distinct colors as possible the way
you would do this
is try and have the distance between
each color
as per the rgb value be as different as
possible
so the first thing that comes to mind is
why don't we light up
or maximize each individual component
that's how we get
a solid red solid green and solid blue
just by having
each of the three components be 255 we
can also do something
like this where we go halfway on each so
you have 128 0
0 and that becomes a little bit of a
darker red and similarly for
this dark green and this dark blue
for the other six colors we can combine
each of these three primary colors so we
can make yellow by combining red and
green
and then i picked a couple others as
well that you're welcome to
copy from me as well so combining these
colors with different icons that we
picked
here's what i came up with on the left
is what i'll name
each icon i see face flower gift and so
on
the second column indicates the name of
this icon in the vector asset studio so
you can find it
and the third column shows you what the
icon will look like with the selected
color
now let's go create these in android
studio let's repeat the process for
creating the face icon several more
times
so we'll right click on drawable go to
new and go to vector asset
the next asset we'll create is the
flower local florist is the name
and we'll change the name in our project
to the ic flower
and we'll change the color to be green
tap on finish and now i'm going to speed
through this for the other 10 icons
[Music]
all right done now we have these 12
different icons
the next step is to reference them in
column code so we can start to use them
in our memory game
so the way i'm going to do this is i'm
going to create a new package
called utils and inside of the utils
it's going to be a
kotlin file called constance
and we're going to now define a list of
these drawables that we just created
so i'll call this default icons
and it's going to be a list of all the
different drawables so i see face
then we have to import resources and
similarly for the other 11 icons that we
created i'm just going to reference all
of them by saying r.drawable dot
the name of the icon now we have this
list variable
called default icons which will be the
icons we use in our memory game
let's go back now into the main activity
let me exit out a couple of these files
and what we would like to do is pass
into the adapter
the list of image icons these drawables
that should make up that game so we're
going to have we're going to end up
adding one more parameter here
the way we'll do this is grab the
default
icons that we just defined i'm going to
randomize
that list and then we're going to take a
certain number
and the number of images that we take
will be board size
dot get num pairs and the reason we want
to do this is because for example in the
eight card memory game we're going to
have four distinct images right
it'll be the number of cards that i bet
you which is what we're doing in get num
pairs
so we're going to take four images out
of the default icons so this is going to
return to us
the set of chosen images for our memory
game
and now what we want to do is we want to
double up those images so we'll end up
with two copies of each image
we'll say randomized images
is equal to chosen images double it up
so we have each image in there twice and
we want to randomize that list by again
calling dot shuffled
and now this randomized images list is
what we're going to pass in to the
adapter
[Music]
so tap on that red light bulb and add
the
randomized images as a parameter tap on
refactor
and then now let's go into the
definition of memory board adapter
and i'm going to rename this to be card
images
it's going to be a list of int these
integers represent
one of these drawable resources so now
we can actually start to reference this
inside of bind so what we want to do is
based on the position we want to grab
the corresponding image
and that should be the image on the
image button
so they set image resource and that'll
be
card images oops we have to actually
make this card images
a private valve so we can reference it
[Music]
now go back here card images and
position let's try it
and looks like we have a build error
here i need to add in the closing
bracket let's try it again this
succeeded
so right now you'll remember in
mainactivity.kotlin we're hard coding in
the board size of hard which means we
have 24
memory cards in the game and you can see
that all the vector icons that we
created are in this board and there are
exactly two copies of each
and because we're randomizing it if i
run this application again
we should see that these images are in
different places so right now we have
this
graduation cap the school icon in the
top left let's run this again
and hopefully that should be in a
different position now so you can see it
is
and then if we also go back into the
easy
version of the board run this now we
should be randomly picking four
images out of the 12 that we have and
there should be two copies of each
placed randomly among the eight
positions and if we run the app again we
should
have chosen different images and they
should be in different positions which
we are seeing here awesome
so now we have this well-defined board
size concept along with a set of icons
to play the game
in the next part we'll start
implementing the game logic
the goal for this segment is to lay the
groundwork for the memory
game logic that will write and the key
observation here
is that every memory card will have an
associated state
so for example a memory card can either
be face up which means that the image
is showing or it can be face down which
is the default state
in how the game starts and so in order
to capture all of that
we're going to create a data class in
kotlin representing one memory card
so open up the project tool window and
inside of the models directory let's
create a new
kotlin file called memory card
[Music]
this is going to be a data class and
the objective here is we want to list
out every attribute
of a memory card so first off is
we're going to capture the idea of an
identifier for the card
this represents the uniqueness of the
memory icon which is the
underlying resource id integer of the
memory card
and this is going to be of type int
because the actual identifier is going
to be a drawable resource that we
defined earlier
the second attribute of a memory card is
whether it's face up or face down
so we're going to define another
attribute called is face up which will
be a boolean
and this will initially be false because
everything will start out all memory
cards will start out
face down there's an important
distinction here
of val versus var a vowel is something
which
once it's set the value of it can't be
changed whereas
var means that the value can be changed
during the course of a memory game we'll
be flipping cards over
which means that the is face up property
will change over time and therefore
it has to be a var on the other hand the
memory card identifier
will never change once it's set so
that's why we made that a vowel
there's one more attribute of the memory
card which is
is matched and that represents if this
memory card has found
its corresponding pair and as you play
the game you're going to be matching up
cards and when you've matched everything
up
you won the game and so this is also
going to be a var
is matched and it'll be a boolean with
initial value of false
okay so now that we have this data class
in main activity.kotlin
each randomized image that we have this
list of images that make up the
memory game each of those will
correspond to one memory card
and i want to create a list of these
memory cards and the way we'll do that
is we're going to utilize the map
function
on randomized images and what that does
is for every element of randomized
images
we're going to do an operation and
create a new list we're going to
transform randomized images into a new
list
in particular create a new memory card
object
we're going to call the constructor
memory card this takes the three
parameters that we just defined
first is it is the identifier and that
will be the current randomized image
that we're mapping over and we refer to
that as
it and then there are two more
parameters here
one which is is face up and third is
is matched because we define a default
value for is face up and is matched
we actually don't need to specify here
so this can be as simple as
randomized images.map memory card of
it and this is now going to return to us
a list of memory cards
and instead of passing in the list of
randomized images i instead will
will want to pass in the list of memory
cards so let's update the third
parameter
of the adapter to be of type memory card
going to memory let's go into the
adapter and change this to be
just cards
[Music]
now we can actually start doing
something interesting with setting the
image resource
by default the image resource should be
face down it should be the default image
and only if the card is face up do we
want to
show the corresponding image and so here
what we're going to do is
grab the card at that position and check
is it face up or not and
if it is face up then we want to
show the drawable image so we'll call
cards position and then passing the
identifier
and otherwise we want to pass in the
default icon which is the face down and
that will be r.drawable
dot ic launcher background and one thing
we can do just to make this a little bit
cleaner is
save the variable of card's position
into a local variable
so what we're saying here is that if the
memory card is face up then we will
use that as the image otherwise we'll
use the background
so if we try this now we should see a
change
such that all the cards are face down
initially and
the next step is when we actually tap on
one of these we would like to be able to
toggle
or switch the value of this property is
face up
before doing that one more thing i'd
like to do is have a separate class
which will encapsulate all the logic for
the memory game
so right now we have a data class which
represents one memory card
but there's also a notion of the game
itself has some state
and we would like to be able to maintain
that in in a class as well
and so we're going to again go back into
the same directory which has memory card
the models class
and let's define a new column file
called memory game
[Music]
and this memory game is going to take in
the
board size and we want to delegate a
responsibility of creating all the cards
into the memory game that shouldn't
happen in the main activity that should
actually happen
inside of the memory game and so let's
add in
as a constructor the board size here
[Music]
the cards are going to be a member
variable in this class
i'm also going to have a couple more
which we're going to add over time but
to start out with we're going to have
one which is
num pairs found and this is going to be
zero when you start the game you have
found no pairs
in the constructor of the memory game
we're going to do the work to populate
these list of memory cards i'm going to
add this in the init block
and the work we're going to do here is
exactly the work that we already did
over here i'm going to copy all this
the idea is that we are constructing the
list of cards
based on the board size we are picking
some random
images and then based on that creating a
memory card data class
so now all we need to do is construct
our memory game
[Music]
and the third parameter of memory board
adapter should be the
list of cards which we can now get a
reference to
using the cards property of the game
awesome so again there's no functional
change here all we're doing is kind of
moving some code around
so it's cleaner to understand where
we'll add logic in the future
the last thing i want to do is changing
the state
of a memory card when we tap on it going
into the memory board adapter
here is where we are getting notified of
a click on an image button and we would
like to notify the main activity
of this click so that the main activity
can then tell the memory game
class that the user has taken some
action and we should update the state
appropriately
and so the standard pattern for doing
this is to define an interface
so let's do that up here it'll be
interface
card click listener
[Music]
and this is going to have one method
called
on card clicked and it's going to take
in a position which is of type int
and the reason why we're defining this
interface is because whoever constructs
the memory board adapter
it will be their responsibility to now
pass in an instance
of this interface and so i'm going to
add one more variable
in the constructor called card click
listener
[Music]
and this is of type card click listener
and now
when an image is clicked we are going to
invoke this
method on the interface so i'll say card
click listener
dot on card clicked with this position
well and so now back in the main
activity we're going to get an error
right here
because we haven't passed in
cardclicklistener object and the way
we'll do that
is by writing the word object and
specifying we want to create an
anonymous class
which is of type cardclicklistener
and here android studio can help us with
this red underline
under object android tells us hey
this is the interface so in order to
implement this you have to
override this one method on card clicked
and so now here is where we can
add logic for toggling the is face up
property of this card
so for now i'm just going to put a log
statement here
just to make sure that we are able to
actually get notified of the card click
back in main activity
and then we need to find a tag for this
let's do that
[Music]
all right let's run it so we're not
expecting any functional change but now
if we open up logcat
so now we're seeing two log messages
every time we click on
one of the cards the first one is coming
from the memory board adapter and the
second one
is main activity being notified of this
card click
at the same position so in the next
segment we're actually going to
write the game logic for being able to
flip over the card and also create
matches our goal now is to implement the
logic
for the memory game so when i tap on a
memory card i should be able to flip it
over
and also there should be some logic to
check if two cards that have flipped
over
are matched this is a interesting
challenge and you'll find that if you
break it down case by case
the code actually becomes quite simple
so in mainactivity.kotlin we have a log
statement here
for when the card has been clicked and
so i'm going to delete that
and let's actually delegate the work of
this into a method called
update game with
flip at this position
all right and the idea here is that this
method is responsible for
updating the memory game with an
attempted flip
at this position all right and so
we're gonna just delegate the work here
into the memory game
and so in order to reference memory game
i need to make this a
property of the class so create property
memory game
and it'll be late init var so late in it
because we know that memory game is
going to be initialized
properly but it will only happen on
create so that's why we're going to add
this as late in it
and then one other variable that i would
like to make into a property
is the adapter so we're going to split
the assignment
and the declaration of the variable
and then we're going to define another
variable which is a property of the
class
called adapter and this is of type
memory board adapter
so now we can reference adapter from
multiple methods and not just the
oncreate method
so in the update game with flip the
memory game itself should be responsible
for handling
what happens in the state of the game
when the memory card at this position
is flipped we're going to create a
method on the memory game class called
flip card and it'll take in a integer
parameter called position
analytics video will help us to create
it
and then i'll put this down here here is
the
game logic that we're going to write to
start out with just to make this simple
why don't we simply change the value
of the is face up property of this card
so i'm going to grab the card
at this position save that into a
variable called card
and then we're just going to say card
dot is face up
is the opposite of what it was so if it
was face down before it's gonna be face
up if it was face up it's gonna be face
down because the user is
flipping it over and so once we've
flipped the card
then we need to tell the recyclerview
adapter
that the contents of what it's showing
has changed and so it should update
itself
and the way you do that is
adapter.notifydatasetchain
let's try it
so now if i tap on any of these you can
see that this underlying
image resource is shown and i can go
back and forth as well so i can toggle
between them
so now let's think a little bit more
about what exactly should happen
when the user attempts to flip over a
card
so for example if i restart the game
if i flip over this card and let's just
pick another one like this
the next card i flip over should
automatically flip
back to the default state the two cards
that are currently flipped over
and so the memory game has to have some
some state or some notion of
which cards have been previously flipped
over and which have not
and as soon as i flip over another card
now both of these
should have gone back down to face down
and if you think a little bit more about
this it really comes down to
exactly three cases so first is there
were zero cards previously flipped over
[Music]
second is there was exactly one card
previously flipped over and the third
valid case is there are two cards
previously flipped over this is the
totality
of what is possible in a valid memory
game you can never
ever have three cards flipped over at
once so now let's go case by case and
figure out how the memory game should be
updated when there were zero cards
previously flipped over all we need to
do is simply flip over that card
there's no need to flip over any other
cards in the game and
there's no way a match could be found
yet because after this turn is over
only one card will leave left over but
you need two in order to make a match
moving on to the next case if there was
one card previously flipped over
we will always flip it over but we also
now want to check whether the two cards
that are
going to now be flipped over if they
match and if they do match we want to
indicate to the user at the ui layer
that the match has been found and we no
longer want to allow these cards to be
selected or flipped over again
and finally in the third case when there
were two cards previously flipped over
we first want to restore the cards and
make them face down again
and then we want to take the card at
this selected position that the user
tapped on and flip that card over
so if you can understand these three
cases then
the rest of the logic is pretty
straightforward and one thing i can
do to make this even simpler is you'll
notice that
this case when there are zero cards
flipped over or there are two cards left
over
they're actually identical and the
reason is because i could just copy over
the same statement restore cards plus
flip over selected card
into the first case and the idea here is
that if there were no cards flipped over
previously
then this restore card is essentially a
no-op so it has no impact
and then we will flip over over the
selected card
and so we've reduced these three cases
down into two cases
that means the only information we need
to distinguish between these two cases
is if there was one card previously
flipped over and in particular the
position of that one card because we'll
need that in order to check if the
images match
this is the key in sight and so what
we're going to do is have a variable
here
called private var index
of single selected card
and the type of this variable will be a
nullable int with initial value of null
because when you make a new memory game
there is no single selected card
so now we can actually start hooking
this
state up into the flip card method
so if the index of the single selected
card is null
what does that mean that means that
there were either
zero cards previously flipped over or
there were two cards previously flipped
over
[Music]
so in this case like we broke down here
in the pseudocode the first thing we
want to do is restore the cards
and then the second thing we want to do
is update
the single selected card to be this
flipped card
right so let's say index of single
selected card is now equal to
this position that was flipped over
so let's define this method restore
cards
and this turns out to be fairly easy
we'll just iterate through the list of
all cards that we have
[Music]
and we want to set the
is face up to be false which basically
means turn everything back to the
default state
there's one caveat here though which is
that if the card isn't matched
then we don't want to do that right so
we only want to
set the card to be face up if the card
is not matched so i'm going to add
exclamation mark here
and say if the card is not matched then
restore it to its default state
awesome so in the else condition this is
when we have
exactly one card previously flipped over
so now as per our pseudo code we need to
flip over the card
and then check if the images match and
so let's
write that logic add a method here check
for match
and we're going to pass into this method
two positions
on the board on the memory board and the
objective is that this
function will return to us true or false
on whether those two positions
on the board are identical images or not
the first
parameter will be index of single
selected card and the second will be
position
and this is going to return to us
whether we found a match or not
so let's define this method check for
match so the first parameter can just be
position one
and the second can be position two
and the return type will be a boolean on
whether a match is sound or not
so if the card at position one
if the identifier of that is not equal
to
the identifier at position two
[Music]
then we know that the user has picked
incorrectly these two cards are not a
match
however if these cards do match then we
need to update the state
of those cards to be is matched is equal
to true because now we found the pair
the user has found the pair so we should
set is match to be equal to true
and if this happens we want to update
this variable
num pairs found and increment it and
then let's hit return true
all right let's see what is the issue or
happening here the num pair is found we
defined it as a vowel
and it actually should be a var because
that will change over time
okay and there's one more error here
saying that smart cast to int
is impossible because index of selected
card is a mutable property
in order to force this to be a
non-nullit i can just use a double
exclamation mark
to tell the collin compiler to not worry
about this
and the last thing we're going to do
here is that if we get into the else
branch which means there was exactly one
card previously flipped over after the
user has
finished flipping the card then there
will no longer be
exactly one card slipped over and so we
need to set index of single selected
card to be
null and the reason i wanted to save
this found match variable is i would
like flip card to return to us a boolean
on whether a match was found or not and
so i'm going to
define a variable up here called var
found match
this is initially going to be false
and then it might turn true
when the user has flipped over two cards
and we're checking the value
and then here we're going to return the
value of found match
before testing this out one more thing i
want to do is in the check for match
method
if our logic is correct we will now set
the boolean property
is matched when cards are indeed matched
and so back in the memory board adapter
we can use that information to update
the ui appropriately
in the bind method based on whether the
memory card is matched or not we will
set the alpha property
of the image button view so the alpha
value
refers to the opacity how visible is the
the image button
and so if the memory card is matched
we'll set it equal to a lower value 0.4
in order to fade it out and make it less
prominent and the
f here stands for float which is a
different kind of number compared to an
integer
and in the else condition we will set
the value to 1.0 which is a default
full bleed opacity and one more thing we
can do here is
if the memory card is matched then
we can change the background of matched
cards to
be a little bit grayed out and the way
you can do that is i can say context
compat
dot get color state list
context r dot color dot
color gray and we're going to define
what that is
also null this is now going to be a
color state list
and we're going to call this method view
compat
dot set background tint list image
button
color state list the idea here is that
the set background tint list is a way to
set a background or shading onto the
image button
and so if the image is matched we're
going to have a
gray background which we create using
contextcompat.getcolorstatelist with the
gray color
and that will be one more visual
indication of the user that this
card has been matched so let's now
define
this color resource so have indirect
video help me to create a color value
resource color gray
and the value is going to be this gray
color
eo times three tap on okay
and just to show you what that did if we
command click or control click on color
gray
it added one more line into the color
xml with the color that we picked
all right let's try it
it looks like we have an error here
invalid color and i think i just forgot
the hash
symbol here all right let's try one more
time
so i'm going to flip over a card flip
over one more and in this case
these cards don't match so we don't
apply
the different ui effect of cards being
matched but now the here's the real test
when i flip over a next card
both of these cards should go back to
being flipped over
let's see if that happens okay awesome
so you can see that
both of these did go back and now we're
flipping over exactly one card
so we're playing a valid game of memory
now
let's see if i can find a match so
here's a house and the other house was
here
so there you can see that we found a
match and that resulted in us having
this gray background color applied to
the
button and the alpha value goes down to
0.4
this is a nice way of telling the user
that these cards have been matched
already
all right we found one more match and
one more thing i want to try here now is
both of these cards are flipped over
let's say now i actually tried to
tap on this graduation cap one more time
that's a little bit weird it actually
led to this memory card being flipped
back to the state and this one stays
flipped over the correct thing to do
here is
not allow the user to make this invalid
move
let's try one more time so if i click
this card again
we're kind of in this bad state now
where
the user is able to tap on something
which shouldn't be a valid move in
memory
that is what we're going to handle in
this update game with flip method
so here we need to do some error
handling
there are two errors that can happen one
is if we've won the memory game
and second is if that memory card is
already face up
so first if we've won the game of memory
this is going to be a method defined on
the memory class on the memory game
class
then we want to return because this
move isn't valid so we want to maybe
alert the user
and the other error case is if
[Music]
the card at that position is already
face up
and then same thing in that case we want
to tell the user that this what they're
trying to do is invalid
and then return early so let's define
have one game
but this is pretty straightforward
because we know how many pairs
have been found that's this variable
here num pair is found
so we know we've won the game when the
number of pairs
is exactly equal to the total number of
pairs that should be in this board
so we'll say board size dot get num
pairs
let's also define this is card face up
method
and again this is pretty straightforward
all we need to do here
is grab the cart at that position and
check the value
of is face up
so in order to check if this actually
worked i would like to
show some ui when either of these things
happen
and the way we can do this is by using a
snack bar
the snack bar is an android component
which shows up at the bottom of the
screen
and you can use it as a way to message
to the user
about something so i'm going to say
snackbar.make
and we need to pass in a view here the
root view
i'll call this yellow root and i'll
define that in just a little bit
i'll say u already one
and then we need to find a length here
snack bar dot length long
and then show it and then
if the card is face up then
invalid here we need to define
the root element on which this snack bar
will be anchored and that's
pretty easy to do all we want to do is
go into the activity main
and this cl root is going to refer to
the constraint layout the very
root element so i'll give this an id of
cl root
go into main activity and let's define
that up here
[Music]
just subtype constraint layout and then
we need to
add it right here clru is able to find
view by id r dot id
cl root okay so hopefully the errors
went away with the snack bar awesome
let's try running this one more time
i flip over a card let's try flipping
over the card one more time
and you can see invalid move which is
great so
in a in actual game of memory you
shouldn't be allowed to flip over the
same card twice
so we have to flip over one more card
after we flip this one over
awesome so if i do the same thing that's
invalid
and let's actually play the game
okay now we've won so now at this point
we shouldn't be allowed to flip over any
card
right so if i tap on any card you can
see that we get that snack bar you
already won
so just to review what we're doing here
is in the update game with flip method
the user is
attempting to flip a card at that at
this position in the
recycler view and we're doing some error
checking to begin with
and then down here we're actually
flipping over the card
and this flip card method returns a
boolean now i'm going to capture that
let's put a log statement here
indicating that we found a match
and let's also print out the number of
pairs that the user has found so far
and that data will come from the
property num pairs found on the memory
game
this is the core game logic for playing
memory so if you have any questions or
confused about anything
drop a comment and i'm happy to help as
much as possible in the next part we're
going to update the text views at the
bottom of the screen
in order to show how the game is
progressing the last part was
quite heavy because we were implementing
the core game logic fortunately this
part
is quite a bit easier because all we
want to do is update the text views at
the bottom of the screen
to show the progress in the game let's
start with the text view showing the
number of pairs found
so right here we are capturing the
return value of memory game.flipcard and
if that returns true
the user has successfully found a pair
of matching memory cards
and so in that case we would like to
reference that text view which is tv
numpairs
and set the text attribute
[Music]
to show this higher number of pairs
found
let's say memory game dot num pair is
found and this is a value
out of the total number of pairs which
is
board size dot get num pairs
[Music]
and here also we can do one additional
check if
the match is found then there's a
potential that the user has also
won the game and so we're going to check
that so if memory game dot
have one game and in that case we just
want to show a message to the user
u1 congratulations
one quick correction from before if the
user has made an invalid move by tapping
on a card which is already faced up i
want to make the snack bar length short
instead of long
the second text view in the bottom is
for the number of moves the user has
made
if the user has gotten past the first
two error checks the user has made a
valid card flip
and so right here we want to update the
textview showing how many moves the user
has made
memorygame.getnum moves
this method doesn't exist yet on the
memorygame
class so android studio can help us to
create it and this is going to return an
int of how many moves the user has made
so the logic here is that as soon as i
flip one card over
i haven't actually completed my move yet
my turn in the game or my move
is only over after i've flipped over two
cards so the number of moves will be
half the number of card flips so we're
going to define
one more member variable or property on
the class
called num card flips this property will
be private because we don't need to
expose
this information outside of the member
game class and a var because
the number of card flips will change as
the game is being played we'll set it
equal to 0 initially because
in a new game there are no cards flipped
yet and we'll increment this num card
flips variable
every time we get into the flipkart
method because we know at that point we
have a valid
card flip now we simply use this value
to compute the number of moves
and we'll just do num card flip divided
by two and notice here that we are going
to be doing integer truncation so if the
number of card flips is five
when we divide by two the result of that
will be two because we're rounding down
and that makes sense because when i've
made five card flips i'm in the middle
of my third move i haven't yet completed
it and so we still want to show
number of moves being two let's try it
so now as we play our game we should see
both of these numbers go up
okay so i made two card flips and then
this makes sense now i
made one move
okay so now i made two moves because i
flipped over four cards total
and i got lucky with this last one and i
found a pair so you can see how this
also got incremented
let's keep going
awesome so now we see the snack bar u1
and the total number of moves is
reflected properly
along with the number of pairs the last
thing we want to do
in this segment is i would like to
actually add in color interpolation
on the number of pairs and this is a
nice visual way for the user to know
using a color their progress in the game
so every time we increment the number of
pairs
we want to also update the color of the
text view we'll say tv numpairs dot set
text
color we're going to pass in a color
here and this color is going to be the
result of
interpolation so interpolation is a
fancy statistical term
but it's actually quite simple if i tell
you that i'm walking a thousand steps
and i'm 75 done then you would probably
tell me
i should roughly have taken 750 steps
and what you're doing in your head is
linear interpolation
at the starting point i've done zero
steps at the ending point i've done a
thousand steps
and so when i say i've done 75 progress
you are estimating that
i should be roughly 750 steps into that
journey
we're doing something identical here
we're going to use a built-in class in
android called argb evaluator
which will take in the worst color
meaning no progress has been made
zero pairs have been found and another
color representing full progress
has been made which means the user has
won the game and all the pairs have been
found
and all we need to do then is provide
progress of how many pairs have been
found so far in the game
and based on that we will do
interpolation between the worst color
and best color
and this is possible because like we
talked about earlier colors are simply
integer values behind the scenes so
here's how we can compute the fraction
of what
progress has been made so far the number
of pairs
found divided by the total number of
pairs and the issue here is that it
expects a float rather than int
so we're going to cast the numerator as
a float
the second and third parameter are the
start and end value representing
no progress made and complete progress
made
and so we're going to use context compat
to get the color and then we're going to
actually define
the colored resource in our colors.xml
file
i'll call the color resources color
progress none and color progress full
so now we will create the color value
resource and what i
put in here is this red color because
red kind of indicates to me that you've
made no progress
you're stopped so that's the burst value
and then for color progress full
i am using this green value which means
that you've made it
green means go so you've you've made a
lot of progress and you've won the game
awesome and then the set text color
requires an integer
and so we're going to now cast the value
of this argb evaluator as an int
let's try it as i make progress
in this eight memory card game there are
four pairs
each time i should be 25 percent closer
to hitting that green value
so after one pair you can see the color
changing a little bit
and now you can see the full green color
at the very end when i've won the game
one thing you'll notice is that at the
very beginning of the game we should
see the color of that text view be red
to indicate no progress but right now
it's that default black color so let's
fix that inside of the oncreate method
after we've defined
tv numpairs let's set the text color of
that text view
to initially be the color representing
no progress color progress none which is
a red color
and if we try it we can see that the
text view color is indeed red
at this point we're able to play a fully
functional memory game
along with having information at the
bottom showing how the game is going
the goal for the next segment is to give
the user some control
to restart the game and also allow the
user to control
what size memory board they're playing
with easy medium or hard
the goal for this segment is to allow
the user to restart the game that
they're currently playing
or to pick a new board size and try a
different game
so let's start out by adding a menu
option for restarting the current game
so let's go into project and go into
resources
and we're going to create a new resource
directory
android resource directory which is of
type menu
inside of this directory we'll create a
menu resource file called
menu main
and let's start out with just one menu
item we'll give this menu option a title
of refresh
but we'd actually like for this action
to have an icon associated with it so
we'll create a new vector asset
called refresh give it a name of ic
refresh
and then tap on finish and we're going
to set the icon
attribute of this menu option to be this
newly created icon
we'd like for this menu option to show
up as an action rather than being buried
by default inside of the overflow menu
which is what we're seeing here
so i'm going to hit the show as action
attribute and hit always
which indicates the android system that
we want this to be an icon
rather than text in the three dot menu
now we have to actually inflate this
menu resource file that we just created
in main activity so there's a method we
will override
called oncreate options menu so if you
just start typing
on create options then you should find
it and we are going to
get the menu inflator and inflate
the r dot menu menu main
and the second parameter here is the
menu which is
the parameter and then we'll return true
because this method on create options
menu requires a boolean return value
now we want to get notified when the
user has tapped on
that particular menu item so first going
back into menu main
we want to add an id i'll call this
mi refresh which stands for menu item
refresh
copy that and then the way we get
notified of
the user tapping on an option menu is
through this method
on options item selected
so here we'll use the when construct so
say when
dot item id so based on the item id
of this menu item we'll take a different
action so the only one we have right now
is r.id.mi refresh
and in this scenario we want to
set up the game again
[Music]
so setting up the game again basically
entails
doing all this logic again where we
create a new memory game
we set up a new adapter and then we set
up the recyclerview
with this new data let's push all of
this logic into a separate function
which we can then
easily reuse so i'll call this setup
board and paste in that logic in the
newly created function
and then my preference is usually to put
all of these private functions
below all of the functions that we're
overriding i'm going to put this down
here
all right awesome so now let's just
simply call
setup board right here let's try it
so hopefully now we should see a menu
option up here where we can refresh
so just click a few of these
and then if i hit this option now i
should be able to refresh the whole game
yep and you can see that now we have
different cards show up
awesome one thing that is worth doing
though is that if i'm in the middle of a
game like this i've already made
three moves and i already have found one
pair i'd like to warn the user
that they're about to lose their
progress on the game
and so right here if the
number of moves in the memory game get
num moves
if that's more than zero and the user
hasn't won the game yet
then we should be showing a alert dialog
to the user
informing them that this is a dangerous
operation because they might
be very close to winning but they
accidentally hit the refresh button for
example so i'm going to delegate that
work of showing the alert dialog to a
method because we're actually going to
show
several alert dialogs depending on which
menu option the user taps on so i'll say
show
alert dialog
and then create a function for this
we're going to leverage the alert dialog
builder in order to create
and show the dialog it takes in a
context we'll pass in a title which will
be passed as a parameter
same thing with the view and then we'll
get to the negative and
positive button click listener a bit but
first let's go back and add the title
and view
as parameters now we'll set the negative
button
text to be cancel and by passing null
here we're basically saying just dismiss
this alert dialog
if the user taps on cancel we're also
going to add in a
positive button which will be okay and
here we need to actually take action
based on the user tapping on the ok
button
if we go into the declaration of set
positive button the second parameter is
onclicklistener which is an interface
which has one method
and that one method has two parameters
but neither of these
is actually relevant to what we need to
do here so in order to indicate that
we're still adhering to that
signature we're going to put in
underscores to say that that's the
method we're
writing and this is where we now need to
take the action
based on what happens when the user taps
on ok
and that has to be something that's
passed in as a parameter to show alert
dialog
so i'm going to add a third parameter
here called positive button click
listener
and that will be of type
view.onclicklistener
now we can call the on click method of
the positive click listener which takes
in
a parameter of u which we don't care
about so we'll pass in null here
so now let's look at how we can use this
in the show our dialogue method we'll
pass
in the title which will be quit your
current game we don't need to show any
additional information so the view of
the alert dialog can be null
and then we're going to pass in the
positive button click listener
which is what should happen when the
user confirms this alert dialog and
we're just going to call setup board
and in the else condition the user is
not in the middle of a game so we can
just unconditionally call
setup board
so if i make some moves like this and
now i refresh
you can see that before setting up the
game again we had this dialog which has
the title that we specified along with
two buttons
cancel or okay so if i cancel all we're
doing is exiting the alert dialog but we
haven't actually taken
action which is what we want on the
other hand if i tap ok
now we are properly resetting the board
which is exactly what we want
one other issue that you'll notice is
that we aren't resetting the
value of these text views properly when
we call
setup board so let's fix that so go into
the setup board method
so depending on the board size we would
like to
reset the value of those text
text views at the bottom so board size
is an enum and so now because it's an
enum we know
what are the possible values of this so
we'll have android studio help us to add
the remaining else branches
in the easy case we'll first set the tv
num move text view and we'll set that to
be equal to the current game being
played which will be easy
and that's a four by two grid and the
number of pairs is going to start at
zero and there are four pairs total in
the medium case
we'll describe that the board is six by
three and the number of pairs total will
be nine
and then finally in the hard case the
board dimensions will be 6x4
and the number of pairs is 12. because
there are 24 cards
so i'm making some moves and so now if i
reset you can see the number of pairs
has gone back to zero
and i also reset this back to a
description of what game we're playing
awesome the next thing we want to do is
add one more menu option which will
allow us to
change the size so right now the only
game we can play is easy but i'd like to
have one more menu option which allows
us to
select easy medium or hard so for that
let's add one more menu option in menu
main
and this one i wanted to actually show
up in the
overflow menu so i'm going to say show
as action never
and the id of this will be mi
new size title will be
choosing size all right so going back
into main activity
in order to handle that menu item being
clicked in the on options item selected
in the when
expression we'll add the id and we'll
create a function called show new size
dialog
one thing i'll also do is add return
true every time that we're handling the
menu item collect both for
the refresh and this one so in this new
function shown in size dialog we're
going to
call that function show alert dialog
that we just created and the title will
be
choose new size we're going to pass in a
view i'll
pass in null for now but that should be
a list of all the different options of
board sizes and then when the user taps
on ok
we should change the value of the board
size variable in the main activity
all right so the objective here is that
we want to
create a new view which allows the user
to pick between
the various board sizes and the way
we're going to do this is have
a radio group and the radio group will
have three radio buttons
easy medium hard and that's how the user
can specify which
game they want to play and so we're
going to
inflate that view similar to what we did
in the adapter
the contacts which is this and we want
to inflate
r.layout.dialog board size
and pass in null for the second
parameter and this is going to return to
us
a board size view
so now we have to define dialog board
size
so hit that red light bulb and let's
create a layout resource
file and then constraint layout is
fine for the new element let's go into
the design tab
i'd like to i'd like to drag out a radio
button group
let's give the radio group an id a radio
group and let's also add
some horizontal constraints on the left
side it'll be 0dp
from the parent and also on the right
side that means we can make the layout
with
0tv or match constraint now let's drag
out
1 2 3 radio buttons let's give the first
radio button an id of rbez
and then give it a updated text of easy
4x2 to describe the game
the second radio button can be rb medium
and the text will be medium which is 6x3
and then the third data button will be
rb hard
and that will have a text of hard six by
four
in the component tree you can see that
red exclamation mark which indicates
error and it says that there's a missing
constraint on the radio group
so if i go into the radio group we can
see that it's actually not vertically
constrained so i'll
add a 0dp top margin from the radio
group to the parent
and that should resolve that issue one
other thing i'll do is
add a left and right margin of 16dp and
8db margin on the top
just so we can create some space between
the radio group and the parent
alert dialog okay so now we have the
dialog board size so this view is fine
so now we want to figure out if the user
taps on the ok button then the code here
will get executed
the value of the board size that we set
in here will depend on which radio group
button was selected and so we need to
first
define that radio group we need to pull
it out of the board size view so i'll do
that now
and the radio group will mandate that
only one of the buttons inside of it can
be selected at a given time
so depending on which of those was
selected which is a checked radio button
id
we will set the board size accordingly
[Music]
so we want to add in three ids here rb
easy
and in that case the board size should
be easy
if the id selected was medium
then the board size should be medium and
otherwise
the board size should be hard
one more thing before we try this out is
when we open up the dialog i want the
current size board to be the one which
is automatically selected
in the in the dialog so depending on the
board size
[Music]
we want to tell the radio group which
items should be checked so in the case
of easy then we want to check the rbez
[Music]
and once we have specified a new board
size then we simply call
setup board and that should take care of
redrawing our whole board before running
this we need to actually pass in the
board size view which we constructed on
77
and pass it into the show alert dialog
method let's run it and see what happens
now we are able to see this radio button
group and we have the easy radio button
selected
because we were playing a 4x2 grid let's
select medium and see
how the recycler view gets updated to
properly show the
18 cards and let's also try out the
hard version so if we go to the dialog
again we see the medium is pretty
selected
and hard shows us the 6x4 grid and you
can also see at the bottom
the game info is also correct the last
thing i want to do in this part is to
update the color of the refresh icon
because it's a little bit hard to see
right now
so this icon is what we just created
it's called ic
refresh and the color of it is dictated
by this
attribute here called android tint so
i'm going to replace that and just
use fff which is white in running the
app again we do see that the
menu icon is now white now we are fully
done
building out the memory game played with
the default icons
in the next part we'll allow users to
create their own custom memory games
by taking photos from their phone and
using that as the
back of each memory card instead of
these icons in this segment we're going
to embark on the creation flow
where the user can create their own
personalized memory game using photos
from their phone the idea is that each
memory card instead of having one of the
default icons that we
have put into the app we're going to
have each memory card be
a photo that the user has picked up so
to start out with we're going to
just add one more menu option here which
will launch the creation flow
so i'm going to go into menu main let's
drag out one more menu item
and then the title here will be create
custom game
let's give this an id of mi custom which
stands for menu item custom
[Music]
and then show us action will be never we
always want this to
be underneath the three dots of the menu
so now that we have that let's go into
main activity
and
here is where we can register some
action to happen when the user taps on
that menu item
i'll say r dot id dot mi custom
[Music]
and then we'll put this into a new
function called
show creation dialog
let's define this create function and
this creation dialog wall should be
quite similar to show new size dialog
because the very first thing we want
before we navigate the user to the
creation flow is we need to understand
what size of a memory game do they want
to create and so we're going to reuse
the exact same
dialog board size here and inflate that
and that will be what we show in a
dialog
before we allow the user to go into the
creation flow
so i'm going to go ahead and just copy
all of this
and now we are going to
show the alert dialogue so i'm going to
copy this now although we're going to
modify
this a little bit so the title of this
other dialogue shouldn't be choose new
size
it should be create your own memory
board
then the view will be the three
different options of memory games
and here we would like to figure out
which board size has been picked once
they tap on the ok
button and so for that that'll be a
local variable called
val desired board size
board
and we're not going to set up anything
here we just we want to navigate the
user
to a new screen or a new activity where
they can actually start
choosing which photos they like one
thing i like to do before going forward
is open up the dialog board size
and have a default radio button selected
so we're going to choose the
easy radio button and what that means is
by default when the user is creating a
new
memory board they're going to be
creating an easy board but they have the
option
to pick medium or hard if they want now
our objective is to create a new screen
or new activity
when the user has tapped on the ok
button of this alert dialog
so open up the same directory where my
activity is located right click on it
and go to new
activity and we're going to choose empty
activity
and call this create activity because
this will be
the screen for creating a new board and
then we'll just tap finish
so the way we navigate between
activities or screens in android is
through something called the intent
system so intents are fundamental to
android
they're basically requests to the
android system or to another application
to do some certain action so the intent
that we're doing here
is an intent to go from the main
activity and launch the create activity
so i'll say val intent is equal to
intent
and there are two parameters in the
intent constructor the first is the
context which is we're going to pass in
this which is referring to the
where we're coming from and the second
parameter is the class that we want to
navigate to
and that will be the create activity dot
java
and now in order to actually navigate to
the create activity we need to
call this method start activity and
there are two versions of the start
activity method one is start activity
and the other is start activity for
result
the start activity for result is
necessary if you want to get some data
back
from the activity that you've launched
so in our case we're going to be
launching the creativity
the user will be creating a brand new
board there and then whenever that's
done
we actually want to get that data back
in the main activity and allow the user
to play that custom game that they just
created
and so we do want star activity for
results because we want to get that
signal back from our child activity
about
what is a newly created game so
i'll say start activity for result and
pass in the intent that we just created
and because we're doing selectivity for
result we also need to pass in a second
parameter which is the request code
i'm going to define that as a constant
called create request code
and we're going to have that be defined
inside of the companion object
of main activity say private const val
create request code and i'll set this
equal to 248.
it doesn't actually matter what this is
as long as it's some unique integer
within your activity 248 is near and
dear to my heart because that's the area
code of where i grew up
in michigan let's test this out by
running the app and what we expect is
when i tap on the menu option to create
a new
board and i confirm the alert dialog by
picking a size
then i should be navigated to a new
screen
which should be empty that should be the
create activity
and we can see that it's an empty
activity and our goal now is to actually
fill out the ui
to allow the user to create this custom
board one piece of information that we
need in order to properly show the
create flow
is what size board does the user want to
create what size game did they choose
and that's actually the data that we
collected
via the radio buttons but we're not
doing anything with that data and so
android has a system with intents to
pass additional data along with
the request to do an action so here
we're making the request to
start the create activity inside of that
intent we're going to put in
an extra and that will be the desired
board size
so the extra has a key and value the key
is always a string
and the value is the the variable that
we want to pass between these activities
so the key i'm going to define as a
constant extra
board size and the value is going to be
desired board size
so we have to define extra board size
i'm going to put this inside of
the constants.kt file that we have from
earlier
[Music]
and this has to be a string so i'm just
going to have the string value be extra
board size
let's import this and the reason i'm
defining extra board size into a
separate file as opposed to within main
activity itself
is because we're actually going to be
referencing extra board size and create
activity and so for anything which is
shared
a shared constant between multiple files
i'm going to put that into
constants.kt rather than defining it
into a single file
now we've added this let's go into
createactivity and let's pull that data
out
from the intent but the way this works
is we
will get the intent and get
the serializable extra extra board size
and we're going to cast this as board
size right
and we're going to save that into a
variable called board size
and actually i want this to be a member
variable so we can reference it
reference it across multiple methods say
private late init var board size and now
we don't need to declare it in the
uncreate function
one more thing i want to do is based on
the board size i want to modify the
title
of the create activity to indicate how
many pictures
does the user have to select from their
phone in order to make
a valid game so the number of pictures
the user has to select will be half of
the number of cards
in that game of memory so for example if
i have a hard game that i picked which
is 24 cards
i need to pick 12 unique images from my
phone
and so that's what i want to communicate
in the title of this
action bar so in order to change the
text we can say support action bar
dot title and then this is going to
complain because support action bar
technically is nullable
and so we can use a question mark
operator which says
only call this attribute if support
action bar is not null
and if that's the case then we want to
set this equal to
some string and we're going to set this
equal to choose picks
0 out of 12 for example so if we pick
the hardboard it would be 12 here if you
pick medium it would be
9 and so on of course we can't hard code
in 12 here so i'm going to define
another variable
which is num images required
so this will be a private bar num
images required and initially this is
going to be negative one
but as soon as we get the intent extra
now we can set this equal to
boardsize.getnumpairs and so now instead
of hard coding in 12 here
i'm going to pass in numbers required
and one more thing i want to do before
we test this out is on the support
action bar
there's an ability to instead of having
the default appearance we can have a
back button which allows the user to
easily exit out of this flow and go back
to the main activity if they want
the way we can do this is say support
action bar
dot set display home as up enabled
and pass in true here that'll modify the
action bar to show a back button
and then we need to actually take some
action when the user has tapped on that
back button this is similar to what we
have done before so i'm going to
override this method on options
item selected i'll say if the item id
is equal to android.r.id.home
then we'll just say finish which means i
want to finish this activity
and go back to the main activity return
through here
and the reason this is android.id.home
is because this id
is defined within the android system the
android sdk this is not a menu item that
we added
so that's why it has the android prefix
here let's try it
to go into the creation flow let's pick
easy
and so now you can see that we have um
the back button and it says choose pix04
which makes sense because they're going
to be eight images in the easy
version of the game so that means we
have to pick four different pictures
if i tap on back then we go back to the
main activity
the last thing i want to do in this
segment is do some quick adjustments
into the ui
in the activitycreate.xml so right now
it's just a blank screen
let's give us give ourselves a bit more
space i'm going to minimize this and
also let's delete some of the
extra files that we don't care about
right now
so by default we have this constraint
layout which is a new element and that's
fine
what i want to do is i want to drag out
a button and this will be anchored to
the bottom of the screen
and this is going to be how the user can
save their newly created game
so i'm going to consider it to the
bottom and also to the right and left
and i want this to take up the whole
screen width because it's a primary
action
this is what the user really is
intending to do when they come to this
screen width will be match constraint so
it takes out the whole width and then
i'm going to have
a 16 dp margin on the left and right let
me zoom in and show you a little bit
closer and then also on the bottom
let's add an 8 dp margin from the bottom
of the screen let's change the
the id to be btn safe
and then let's also give this text
of safe one thing that we'll want to do
is by default the user shouldn't be
allowed to tap on this button because
they haven't actually provided the
correct data in order to create this
game right like it doesn't make sense to
save the game without having chosen some
images which we'll do in the later on
and so to start out with search for this
attribute called enabled
and we're going to set this to be false
so that grays out that button it looks
good
and then one more widget i want to drag
out
is an edit text
and this edit text represents the name
of this custom game that the user is
creating
so i want this to also be full width so
drag this to the left and right
and have it also be 16 dp on the left
and right side of the screen
and then i want it to be constrained to
the top of the save button
let's give it a margin of 8 dp from the
bottom
and the width can be matched constraints
it takes out the whole
screen with let's change the input type
to just be
text we don't want this to be a person
name we just want it to be regular text
and by default there should be no text
here that's for the user to fill out
but we do want to give the user a hint
of what should be
what what they should write in this edit
text so in the hint
attribute i'm going to write game name
example
panda fun
and just a few more things before we
wrap up first off
i would like to set an attribute called
digits on this edit text
so search for digits
and what digits represents is what is
the valid allowable input
in this edit text this game name that
the user writes
is going to be living in our database
that we'll get to later
and so we want to be we want to
constrain what the user is allowed to
actually put in here
you can kind of copy what i did i'm
allowing the user to enter in
any of the digits one through zero
through nine
or a b c d all the lower case
letters or underscore or dash
that's it so there's no slashes allowed
no question mark no period things like
that
and the reason for this is because i
want it to be easy for people to be able
to
share the game name so for example panda
underscore fun is a valid game name and
that's also easy for me to
communicate out to someone else as soon
as we start introducing uppercase
lowercase letters
or slashes or things like that that will
make it harder to communicate
the game name to other people and also
it actually might cause some issues
in our database so it's better to
constrain the user input here
a couple other things i played around
with this a little bit i want to set the
ime options
to be done action done and what that
will do is they'll
change the keyboard to have a check mark
at the bottom right to indicate to the
user that
they've finished filling out this field
and
we can also change the id here to be et
game name
so it stands for edit text game name and
if you go into the code tab
there's one more change i want to make
which is called important for autofill
i'm going to set this to
no and what this means is that we don't
want the
android system to be over eager and auto
fill this field
and finally specify the maximum number
of lines allowed in this edit text which
will be
one that basically means that there are
no line breaks allowed in this edit text
which
kind of makes sense we want the game
name to be short concise and fit onto a
single line
let's try it so now when we navigate
into the creation activity then we
expect
to see this ui at the bottom of the
screen
awesome so you can see the button is
disabled and we have this
edit text which has the hint that we
specified and
i can type in abcd and the letters like
that
but if i try typing in a question mark
you'll see that it doesn't actually show
up same thing with capital letters or
slash and so on so that looks like it's
working
awesome so we have the shell of the ui
for our create activity
in the next segment we're going to start
flushing this out a little bit more
by allowing the user some ui where they
which they can tap
and select photos from their phone the
goal for this segment
is to continue to flesh out the ui for
the create activity
and in particular we want to show a grid
of gray
boxes which will be a indication of the
user to tap on those in order to pick an
image from their phone
and the way we'll do this is actually
quite similar to what we've already done
with the main activity
we're going to have a recyclerview which
has a grid
layout manager and that'll be how we
construct this grid of
images or grid of gray boxes for now the
first thing i want to do is
in the activity create in the design tab
let's drag out a recyclerview
let me zoom out a little bit so i want
this recyclerview to be constrained to
the
right end of the parent and left end of
the parent
that's how we get zero and zero over
here also concerning to the top of the
parent
and the bottom should be actually
constrained
to the top of this edit text and in
order
to have this to actually take an effect
we have to change the layout width and
height to be
match constraint
awesome so you can see how the recycle
view now is taking up whatever is
remaining
after subtracting out these bottom
components
let's give this an id of rv image picker
now in the create activity the first
thing i want to do is get a reference to
the three views on the screen the
recycler view
the edit text and the button so all
these will be late in it var because
we're going to declare them
as member variables but actually set the
value in oncreate
so we'll just say rv image picker find
viva id with the corresponding id
and similarly for the edit text and save
button similar to the main activity the
recyclerview will have two core
components the adapter and
the layout manager the layout manager is
easier so
that'll be equal to the grid layout
manager will pass in the context which
is this
and the second parameter is the number
of columns that'll be the get with
method on the board size one thing we
can also do here is similar to the main
activity
i'm going to call this method set has
fixed with
set this equal to true because we are
guaranteeing that the recyclerview
dimensions won't change because we've
allocated just enough space for it
and now we want to set the adapter so
i'm going to say
rv image picker dot adapter and we're
going to set this equal to an image
picker adapter
and this is the class that we're going
to define
this will take in three parameters first
is the context
and then we are going to pass in a list
of the images that the user has chosen
and so i want to define that as another
variable up here
call this private val chosen
image uris there's going to be a mutable
list
of uri so a uri we're able to import
this
is a uniform resource identifier you can
kind of think of it like a string
which unambiguously identifies where
does a particular resource
live and so the resource in our case is
an image this is an image which
lives on the phone it's physically
stored on the phone the uri
is describing what is the directory path
to locate this photo so when the user
has picked
two or three photos for example there
will be two or three elements in this
list two or three uris
so that'll be the second parameter and
the third parameter will be the board
size
let's have android studio help us to
create this class we'll extract it to a
separate file
and the first parameter i'll rename it
to be context the private vowel context
second parameter is the chosen image
uris and i want this to be just a normal
list and not a mutable list
and the third parameter is the board
size and all of these should be private
val
just like before we would like to define
an inner class
view holder and that will be what we
parameterize the constructor of the
image picker adapter by so i'll define
inner class view holder which inherits
from recycler
view holder and once we define this
inner class now we can go ahead and
override the three members or three
methods of the adapter
okay so the get item count is
straightforward the number of images
that the user has to
pick is the number of pairs in this game
so if i have a 24 card memory game then
the user has to pick 12 images and we
should be returning 12 here
that'll be board size dot get num pairs
that's why we passed in the board size
as a constructor parameter
and now let's implement the
oncreateviewholder so again this is
going to be quite similar to what we
already did
in the memory board adapter i'm going to
call layoutinflator.from
passing the context which is a
constructor parameter
i'm going to inflate a custom
layout file that we'll define i'll call
it card
image parent
and false this is going to be a view
and let's now define this card image
resource file
i'm going to have the root element here
be a linear layout because we can keep
this
file a little bit simpler and this is
going to be
really straightforward there's no need
to embellish the design with any kind of
card elevation or rounded
edges or anything like that so the only
thing we need to do is drag out an image
view
well and so i want to just hard code the
width and height just to make this look
a little bit more realistic
to be 100 dp each
give this an id of iv custom image
and let's change the scale type to be
center crop
just like we had done earlier
and let's also provide some margin on
this element just so that the
card views that we show in the creation
and the creativity
aren't glued next to each other there's
going to be some space in between them
so i'll search for margin here
and set this equal to 8 dp
cool one more thing is that
the parent element the linear layout i
want the
height of this to be wrap content and
then finally
we want the image view inside of the
linear layout to be centered so we're
going to set the gravity
of the linear layout to be center
and one more thing we can do here also
is on the image view
if there is no image selected which will
be the default state
then i want to see the background color
of the imageview
and we're just going to have this be a
hard-coded color
which is coming from the android system
called darker gray
and you can't see that in the preview
because we are using this
sample image but you'll see it when we
run the app
so going back to the image picker
adapter now we have this proper
card image that we're inflating and
similar to what we did last time this
image view it shouldn't have a hard
coded height of 100 dp
we should instead be making proper use
of the space
of the screen and so we're going to do
something quite similar
so i'm going to look at the width of the
parent which is the recycler view how
much space have we allocated for the
recycler view
and i want to partition that up into
however many
images the user should pick across so
that's the board size
dot get width that'll be the card with
and then the card height the maximum
allowable card height
will be the height divided by the number
of rows in our board which is board size
dot get height
and again similar to last time we're
going to define a card side length which
is
the minimum value of the card width and
the card height so we're gonna have to
import math.main from kotlin
and so now we can grab a reference to
this
image by using the id so i'll say
view which is the linear layout plus the
image view and then inside of that view
we're going to find
the image view with this particular id
r.id.iv custom image we're going to get
the layout parameters
and on the layout parameters now we can
set the width and height to be the card
side length that we just computed
[Music]
and finally the return value of this
oncreateviewholder is a viewholder
so we're going to construct this new
view holder class
and pass in the view
that we inflated we can actually make
this card height a valve just because
we're not changing any of these again so
similar to
a view card with card height because
these values are not changing
we can set all these to be val and
finally the onbindviewholder method
so the intention here is given a
particular position we want to
define how do we display the ui there
are two cases
here so if you think back to the second
constructor parameter the list of image
uri so let me show you rename this to be
just image uris
so if the position that we're binding
here is
less than the size of the image uris
that means
that means that the user has actually
picked an image for this position and we
should show that image
on the other hand if the position is
larger than image uris
the size of image uri something that we
should just show the default kind of
gray background to indicate to the user
that they still need to pick an image
if the position is less than image
uris.size
that means that we should showing the
image selected in the image view so
i'll delegate the work there to be in
this bind method so i'll say
imageuris.position
on the other hand if position is
greater than or equal to the size of the
image uris the user hasn't yet picked an
image at this point so we'll just say
holder dot bind there's not really much
to do but we're just going to define
this method dot bind
so there are two methods now that we're
going to find in the view holder one
which is bind without
any parameters and the other has one
parameter which is the
uri at that position the view holder is
wrapping the custom
view that we defined in card image.xml
so we'll grab a reference to the
image view by saying private val iv
custom image and that'll equal
the find view by id on the item view
now that we have a reference to the
image view in the first version of the
bind method the one which takes in a uri
all we need to do
is set the image uri on that ib custom
image
and the other thing we'll want to do is
set a null click listener
which basically means that we don't want
to respond to clicks on this
image view so in the second case this is
where we want to actually
be able to listen for the user tapping
on this square
on this image view because that will be
an indication that they want to choose
an image
so what we'll what we'll do is say iv
custom image.set on click listener
and we'll implement this in the next
part the goal is to launch an intent
for the user to select photos let's try
it
and see what it looks like so as our app
gets a little bit more complicated
one thing that's worth investing in is
thinking about how can we
improve the efficiency of getting to the
creativity right now we have to go to
the menu
tap on a couple different buttons and
then finally get there one thing we can
do which is a hack for
developer efficiency is back in main
activity in the oncreate function
we can directly create the intent to
navigate to the create
activity so this will be similar to what
we're doing when we
tap on the menu option but we'll just do
it right away so i'm going to create a
new intent
pass in the medium board size and then
launch the activity right away
this is definitely not something that we
want to ship to production but in
general
anytime you have an opportunity to
improve the efficiency
with which you develop it's worth
investing in so now when we start the
app
you can see we get a brief glimmer of
the main activity but now we're
navigating directly into the create
activity
we're seeing nine gray squares here
because we hard coded in the board size
of medium
and what these gray squares are
communicating to the user is that they
can tap on them in order to select a
photo from their device and that will be
what's used
in order to create their custom memory
game one quick improvement we can make
is if i scroll up or down in the
recycler view we see this purple shadow
which communicates to the user that
there's no more content in the recycler
view
but that doesn't make sense in our
context because we are
guaranteeing the size of the
recyclerview so if we go into the rv
image picker
and look for over scroll mode then we
can set that to never and
address that issue hey one quick tip i
wanted to share with you
if you're using an emulator like i am
then in the next part we're going to be
using
some photos that live on your phone or
on your emulator
as part of building out the app and so
if you're like me
you probably don't have some photos by
default on the emulator
and so i wanted to show you really quick
how you can do that so
if you have a image
like this one then all you need to do in
order to have it show up in your
emulator is drag and drop it
onto the emulator and that'll copy the
file and now in order to have it show up
open up the list of all apps and look
for photos
or whatever is your gallery app on your
emulator
open up that gallery app and i found
that sometimes it's helpful to force
restart the photos app and then open it
up again and hopefully we should now see
this new photo that we drag and dropped
onto the emulator
now we can see the image that was
previously on our laptop and now it's on
our emulator
so this is the easiest way for you to
take images that are on your computer
drag them into the emulator and then you
can use them
in subsequent parts when we start to
build out
the ability to choose photos from your
phone in order to customize the memory
game
in the next segment we'll hook up the
behavior of what should happen when a
user taps on these
grey image views in this segment our
goal is to hook up the click listener
when the user taps on any one of these
gray squares or image views in the
recycler view
and the way we'll do this is once again
quite similar to what we did with the
main activity
which is that in the image picker
adapter we're going to define an
interface
and that interface will have one method
indicating
indicating that the user has tapped on
this element
and that will be how the create activity
gets informed of
a click and the create activity is what
will launch the
flow for allowing the user to pick a
photo from their device
so let's define an interface here
image click listener
[Music]
and then this is gonna have exactly one
function inside of it inside this
interface
called on placeholder clicked
and the final parameter of the adapter
is going to be an
instance of this image click listener
class so private vowel
image click listener and it's of type
image click listener
in the view holder when we bind the set
on click listener on the image view
we're going to invoke the on click
listener method
of the interface so we'll say on
placeholder clicked
for image click listener and so now back
in creativity
we need to pass in this fourth parameter
which is the instance
of the interface so right object here
and this is defining an anonymous class
which implements the interface
image click list center
and there's one method we need to
override and integrate will help us with
that
and tap on implement numbers and here is
where now
play on placeholder click means that the
user has tapped on one of these gray
squares these image views
and so here is where we're going to
launch the photo
choosing flow and i'm going to delegate
that into a method
called launch intent for photos
so this is the second time we're dealing
with intents now we had one intent to go
from the main activity to the create
activity
we're also going to have an intent here
to launch
the flow for the user to pick a photo
and this is called the implicit intent
because we don't actually
care which application on the phone will
handle this intent this request but we
just want
the user to choose either google photos
or a gallery app or something else on
their phone which will allow them
to pick an image for our application to
consume so what we had earlier was an
explicit intent because we were
explicitly navigating to this
create activity and here the create
activity is going to launch an implicit
intent to allow the user to choose an
image
so let's define this method
and i'll put this at the bottom below
all of the overwritten methods
and here we're going to have an intent
and because this is an implicit intent
we're going to just pass in
uh intent action here intent dot
action pick and there's a
property on the intent called type and
we're going to pass an image slash star
communicates that we only really care
about images we don't want
video files or pdfs or any other kind of
file
and we'll pass one extra into the intent
we'll say intent.put extra
and this is a constant on the intent
class intent.extra allow multiple
so extra allow multiple is a constant
defined on the intent class
so this is the key and the value is true
basically what this means is
if the app that the user opens up
supports it we want to allow the user to
select
multiple images and this is valuable
because if i have to pick 12 images one
at a time that can get tedious
instead i might say i want to pick all
the photos from today
have all of them be imported into my
application
so once we have this now we can say
start activity for result
and we're going to say intent dot create
chooser and we're going to pass in the
intent that we just created
called intent and then the second
parameter is
a car sequence or a string we'll pass
and choose picks here
[Music]
and this is basically some text which
which shows up when the user has
multiple apps on their phone that can
service this request
and the second parameter to start
activity for result similar to last time
is a request code
so i'm going to define a request code
pick photos request code
and we're going to define this inside of
the companion object of create activity
so inside the companion object
we will define this constable pick photo
code and i'll set it equal to
655 which is the street address of my
favorite dorm
at stanford brainerd hall one really
important observation about what we're
doing here
is that with this request our
application is going to
need access to files on the user's phone
and by default
the android system doesn't give your app
this permission this is where we're
going to have to request
permissions in the android permission
model the first thing we'll do is open
up the android manifest file
and at the top let's declare that our
application uses this permission
and the permission is called read
external storage because for example if
the photo is located in the downloads or
document
directory of the phone we're going to
read that location of storage which is
external to our app
there are two kinds of permissions in
android normal and dangerous
read external storage is a dangerous
permission and what that means
is just writing user's permission read
external storage
in the android manifest isn't enough for
our app to actually
exercise that permission instead
at runtime the user has to be shown a
dialog
which informs them that this app my
memory
is trying to use this permission do you
want to allow it or reject it
and so that's what we're going to
implement next so
before we call this launch intent for
photos
function we need to check if the user
has granted the permission or not
i'll say if is permission granted
then we can go ahead and call launch and
temper photos like normal
but if not then we need to actually
request permission
what i've written here is pseudocode so
it won't actually compile
but i just want to walk through the
logic if the permission is not granted
then we
need to first request permission and
then get a call back
if the user has accepted and then once
again call launch intent for photos
to properly implement these we need to
make calls into
android system functions and i always
have a hard time remembering them and i
find them a little bit verbose and
hard to parse and so i'm going to create
a utility class
called permission utils and have all the
messiness of interacting with the
android permissions api
in that class inside of permission utils
we'll define two functions
first is permission granted and this
will take in a context
and a permission string and it'll return
a boolean on whether the permission is
granted or not
and the body of the function will be
context compat
check self permission with the context
permission and we see if the return
value of that is equal to package
manager dot permission granted
the second function is request
permission which takes in three
parameters
first is the activity which you'll need
to import
the permission which is a string and a
request code which is an integer
and the body of the function is activity
compat.request permissions with the
activity
we need to pass an array of permissions
so we'll construct that in line
right here and then the request code
so back in create activity let's
actually use these permission utils
functions in is permission granted the
first parameter will be a contact so
we'll pass in this at create activity
and the second parameter is a string
representing the permission so for that
i'm going to define
it as a constant called read photos
permission in the companion object
and this will be coming from
android.manifest.permission read
external storage
to pass that in for the second function
request permission i first want to
define the request code
so i'll say read external photos code
and make it equal to 248
doesn't really matter what it is but as
a best practice we should keep the two
request codes distinct in request
permission the first parameter is the
activity so i'll pass in this at
creativity
second is the permission which is read
photos permission and the request code
is what we just defined
we're almost done now this request
permission function is going to launch
an android system dialog
asking the user if they want to allow my
memory this app
the read external storage permission
regardless of whether the user accepts
or rejects we will get a call back
called on request permissions result and
that's what we'll override
there are three parameters here the
first is the request code and the third
one which is what we'll care about is
the grant results
so the first thing we'll do is check if
the request code is equal to the read
external photos code that we
used to launch the permission dialog
then we'll check the grant results and
it should be
non-empty because we're getting the
results here and we'll check if that is
equal to permission granted which means
that the user
has granted the permission if this
happens we can go ahead and call
launch intent for photos if not the user
has rejected
our app from getting the permission and
we should inform the user
the impact of this so we'll show a toast
and we'll tell the user in order to
create a custom game
our app needs to have permission to get
the photos from their phone
let's try it and once you're on the app
and we tap on one of these image views
these gray
squares if we've done our job correctly
we should now see an android system
dialog
asking if we allow this application the
read external photos permission so tap
on it
and you can see we do have this pop-up
show up and this is a dialog that we
didn't write it's coming from android
so let's actually start by hitting deny
and then we get the toast that we wrote
now let's show one more time and let's
allow it
and now as a result of that implicit
intent an application on the phone is
opened up google photos which allows us
to pick
one or more photos that we can then
surface in the my memory app
let's go ahead and pick these set of
three images
and tap on done and you'll see that we
don't actually update the ui at all
with the images that we get back from
the intent from the on
activity result and so let's fix that
and show the images here
back in create activity the place that
we're launching the implicit intent
is right here and when we call start
actually for a result
whatever is the result of the launch
activity we'll come back
in a function that we're going to
override called on activityresult
the first thing i want to do in
onactivityresult is check
the request code does that match up with
the request code that we passed in
pick photo code that we passed in to
launch the activity do those match
if so then we know that we're getting
we're processing the auditive results
for the right intent and actually i'd
like to do the negation of this
because there are several cases where we
know the data we get back is invalid if
the request codes don't equal
if the result code is not activity dot
result okay
or if the data is null in all three of
these cases we should log a warning and
return early because
we won't be able to find valid photo
data
so we're going to add a log statement
here and we'll log at the warning level
log.w
did not get data back from the launch
activity user likely cancelled
the selection flow now let's go up and
define the tag in the companion object
private cost val tag is equal to create
activity
and if any of these conditions are met
we will simply return early
on the other hand if we've gotten this
far in the function we know we have
valid data inside of the data intent and
i've tested this
on several different devices and based
on my experience
there are actually two different
attributes that we care about on the
data intent
first if the application that's launched
in order for the user to pick a photo
only supports picking one photo then
the selected photo will come back in the
data.data attribute and that'll be a uri
on the other hand if the application
launched
supports picking multiple photos and
either picks multiple photos
then that data will come back as part of
data.clip data
and we will prefer to use the clip data
because that will have multiple images
and the first thing we'll do is check if
clip data is not equal to null
and in that case we'll log at info level
the clip data num images how many items
are in the clip data
along with the actual contents of the
clip data object
now we're going to iterate through the
clip data so i'll say for i
in 0 until the clip data item count
we'll retrieve the
clip item at that position in the clip
data
and now what we'll do is we want to get
the
image uri out of the clip item object so
we're going to add this
image uri into the chosen image uris and
you'll remember we pass
in the chosen image uris into the
adapter and so having the image show up
in our recycler view is as simple as
adding it into
chosen image uris so first we'll check
if we still need to populate the chosen
image uris
check the size and if so then we can go
ahead and add
the clip item.uri into the chosen image
uris
the other case is if selected uri is not
null
so in that case we'll log the selected
uri with a tag
and just print it out and we'll also add
it to the chosen image uris list
the reason we're able to add selected
uri unconditionally in this case
whereas before we had to check the size
of the chosen
image uris list is because if we get
into this method on it to be result
that means the user has tapped on the
gray placeholder image view
and that means there's space for at
least one more image in the chosen image
uris list
on the other hand in the case of clip
data the user might have picked an
arbitrary number of images for example
20 images
but we only want the amount specified by
num images required
that's why in every iteration of the for
loop we check how many images are in our
uri list
now we have added the image uris into
the list so we can notify the adapter
that the underlying data set has changed
in order to do that we need to make
the adapter a property or a member
variable of the class
so let's do that
well adapter is equal to that and i'll
just set
the image picker adapter to be adapter
and now this adapter it shouldn't be
locally defined it should be defined as
a member variable so let's do that
private late init var adapter
image picker adapter and so now let's
get rid of the declaration here
and just set this equal to the property
awesome so now coming back here you can
say adapter dot
notify data set changed one more thing
we should update
is the title of the activity which
informs the user how many images they've
picked so far
so on the support action bar we'll we'll
update the title attribute
to say choose picks and now the
numerator will be
the size of chosen image uris and the
denominator
will similar to last time be the number
of images required
all right let's try it out okay so we're
in the creation activity
let's go ahead and grab all three of
these images
awesome so we can see right away that
the first three
image views in our grid of nine are
populated with those
images that we picked and if we look at
logcat
we can see the log message from the
creativity at info level
which says the clip data num images is
three which makes sense because that's
how many images we're seeing in our
recycler view
let's also try out the case where we
only pick one image
so we'll tap on the great image view
which is a placeholder
and select the image of rochester
downtown
tap on done and now we can see that gets
populated and again the logcat shows
that this is
clip data which means that we're falling
into the case of the clip data not being
null
so on this phone we are always getting
clip data back i have found that in some
phones or in some applications where
you're not allowed to select multiple
images that's when you get into the case
of the selected uri
not being null try it out on your phone
and see what happens
one more thing worth pointing out is
that once an image is
shown in an image view you can no longer
click on it
so if we go into image picker adapter
we're setting the click listener to null
and that's what
is preventing the click from being
registered and that's a product decision
that once an image is picked then the
user has no ability to change it
and if you wanted to you could modify
this behavior to allow this kind of edit
functionality but for now we're going to
leave it as is
notice at the top of the activity we
have the action bar title
to say choose picks 4 of 9 and looks
like i
am missing the ending parenthesis so
let's go into creativity and fix that
there's one final thing i want to get
started on in this part
which is the logic to enable or disable
the save button
there are two conditions that must be
met in order to enable the save button
first all the images must be selected so
in this case we have nine images all of
them have to be valid images
and second there has to be a valid game
name in the edit text
and so when either of those two
components on the screen changes that's
when we might
be enabling the save button so in the
bottom of the
audit tv result which means that the
image has been selected
i'm going to call this method should
enable save button
this function is responsible for
deciding whether we should enable the
save button or not
but for now let's simply return true and
try this out
so now as soon as i select any image and
i
come back into the create activity now
you can see how the save button is
enabled because we're turning through
there
nothing happens when i tap on that
button the handling of that
will happen in subsequent parts this was
a really critical part of the creation
flow dealing with permissions
and intents and filling out these images
in the grid view
all right this segment should be a
little bit lighter our goal is
to properly figure out whether we should
enable the
save button based on if the user has met
the two conditions in order to save a
new game
first is they have to have picked out
every image and second they have to
fill out a custom game name
the first condition is if the size of
the chosen image uris list
is not equal to the number of images
required and that means the user hasn't
picked enough images
for the memory game size desired and in
this case we'll simply return false
the button should not be enabled the
other condition is around the length of
the game name
the user creates for this memory board
obviously an empty name is invalid but
we also want to mandate a minimum length
of the name for example a single letter
like a
or b shouldn't be a valid name so we're
going to have two conditions
if the et gamename.txt if it's blank
or if the length is less than three
then we want to return false and
otherwise we can return true which would
enable the button
we're currently calling this method
should enable save button whenever the
user has picked an image but we also
would like to call it
whenever the text of that edit text at
the bottom for the game name has changed
so in the oncreate method we're going to
add a text
change listener on et game name
we have to provide as the parameter a
text watcher
so the object text watcher and this has
three methods that we need to override
and we only really care about the first
one after text change so i'm just gonna
delete the body for the other two
and leave them as empty and the logic
here is very simple we're simply going
to call that method should enable save
button again and that will dictate
the is enabled property of the btn save
so every time the user makes any
modification in that edit text
we will potentially enable the save
button one more thing that we should do
here
is set a maximum length of the
game name so if the text of the game is
too long it'll
be painful to share with friends and
family and so we're going to restrict
the maximum length to be
14 characters and this turns out to be
pretty straightforward
there's a filters attribute on the edit
text and we are going to
set that equal to an array of filters
and we're going to pass in one filter
and it'll be an inbuilt filter
called inputfilter.lengthfilter and we
pass in
14 which is the maximum allowable length
the result of what we've done
is that the minimum length of a game
name is 3 characters and the maximum is
14.
this is a general good engineering
practice which is always
validating user input no matter what the
user does the application should never
crash
and the steps you've taken here help to
prevent anything unexpected from
happening
along those lines one more good practice
is to define constants for these key
values for example
the minimum game length and the maximum
game length can both be constants so min
game
name length will be 3 and max will be
14. so now it's very obvious
in the code what these magic numbers
represent
so i'll pass in the max game length and
the min game length as appropriate
awesome so at this point if the save
button is enabled based
on the logic we wrote the user should be
able to
take the data that they've collected and
save all that to firebase so anyone in
the world can play
their custom memory game so in order to
make that happen
let's add a click listener on the save
button
and the code that will execute when the
button is clicked
is going to be a method that we're going
to define in a little bit
called save data to firebase
this method is responsible for taking
all the images and the associated game
name and saving that to firebase
so let's have another studio create this
function and i'm going to move this
pilot function
down below any of the other override
functions that we have
the actual logic of integrating with
firebase we will do that in a
subsequent segment but for now i want to
put a log statement here
and i want to write some logic for down
scaling the image
and the reason why i want to downscale
is because the images
typically on your phone are going to be
quite large more than a megabyte or two
megabytes
and we're only showing you the image in
the memory game in a very small square
so downscaling the image means that we
are able to
use up less storage in firebase storage
and also when we download the image
it'll be faster download if you only
have a few hundred users
then the amount of storage you're going
to take up on firebase storage
is going to be minimal anyway so feel
free to skip this part if you're not
interested
but it's also something interesting to
learn about
so let's put a log statement here
and i'm going to have a for loop which
now iterates over
the chosen image uris and we're going to
iterate
through it with both the index and the
element and i'll call that photo uri
so we'll have this chosen image uris
that with index
so i'm going to find a method called get
image byte array
and this will take in a photo uri
and this will return to us a image byte
array
and that image battery is what we're
actually going to be uploading to
firebase storage
and this method is going to take care of
all the
downgrading of quality that we want so
let's define this method
and the return type should be a byte
array
the first thing we'll do here is get the
original bitmap
based on the photo uri and this will
depend on the api version of the phone
that this app is running on
so i'll call this original bitmap
and if the build.version.sdkint
is greater than or equal to p which is
android pie then the way to get the
original webmap
is by using something called
imagedecoder.createsource
content resolve a photo uri and then we
call imagedecoder.decodebitmap with that
source otherwise if we're running a
lower version
then we'll say
mediastore.images.media.getbitmap
contentresolver with the photo uri
so this conditional is interesting what
it means is that if the
phone operating system that we're
running on is running android pi
or higher then the original bitmap will
come from running those two lines of
code
and otherwise on an older version we'll
run this one line of code in order to
get the
original bitmap now let's log the width
and height of the original
map so we can compare the size now
versus after we scale it down
so we'll log at the info level original
bitmap.width and originalbitmap.height
so i'm going to invent a method here
called
dot bitmapscaler.scale to fit height
passing the original bitmap along with
250. let's define this class now
i'm going to extract it to a separate
file and put it into the utils
directory tap on ok and the idea of
bitmap scalar
similar to permissionsutil.kotlin which
we defined earlier
is simply to create a nicer looking api
or nicer looking method
around some of the android apis so
rather than typing out the code i'm just
going to paste it in
and then we can talk about it so as the
comments describe
the intention of these methods is to
keep the same aspect ratio of the bitmap
but scale it down as per the width or
height passed in
you can read through the math that's
happening here in order to
scale the bitmap appropriately it's not
that complicated but the broader point
here
is that whenever you're able to take
something complicated
or harder to understand and wrap that
around something simpler
that's a big win computer science is
largely about
communication and what we've done here
is we've taken something which is
harder to communicate and wrap that
complexity into something
which makes it much simpler and that's a
huge win now let's
turn this into an object because this is
a utility class it doesn't make sense to
have multiple instances of a bitmap
scalar so
we can just call bemouthscaler.scale2fit
height with a height of 250
and once we've done that now let's print
out the scaled bitmap width and height
the last thing we need to do in this
function is to return
the byte array and so at the
bottom of the function we're going to
define a new byte array output stream
we'll take our scaled bitmap and then
call the compress method on it
and we'll pass in a compressed format of
jpeg
the second parameter is the quality
reduction hundred means no reduction in
quality
and zero means a severe downgrading
quality so we'll pass on 60 here
and then we'll pass in the byte array
output stream that we just defined
and finally we'll return byte output
stream dot 2 byte array
so at this point we have gone through
and down scaled the quality
of each image the user has selected the
job for the next part will be to figure
out how to upload this
to firebase storage at this point we
have the list of all the images that we
want to upload to firebase
and we've downscaled them appropriately
and we are now converting them into a
byte array which is
what firebase will take in in the upload
process
so in this segment we're going we're
going to write the core logic for
taking these photos and actually
uploading them
to firebase storage this will obviously
require
the use of the internet in order to
communicate with our client our android
device
to firebase storage so let's open up
android manifest
and add in the internet permission
one thing to observe here is that
internet is a normal permission
while read external storage is a
dangerous permission which means that we
don't need any of the
runtime permission logic that we needed
for read external storage we get
internet permission for free
in order to now upload this into
firebase we need to have
a new firebase project so what you
should do is
go to console.firebase.google.com let's
tap on add project
and let's call this project my memory
[Music]
continue and then let's disable google
analytics for now
it's not strictly required for what
we're building
and now firebase will take a couple
seconds in order to
build out your firebase project
all right so we're done let's tap on
continue
and we're going to add an app an android
app to get started so we're going to
associate our android app to this
firebase project so for the packaging
let's go back into android studio
go up to the very top and then here is
our package name
which is the thing that we had defined
at the beginning when we were creating a
new project
copy that i'm going to leave the rest of
this blank it's a register app
and now we need to download this file
google services.json
and what we want to do is we want to
actually drag this into
the app directory the way we can do this
is
as shown in that photo go into the
project tool window
go into the project perspective of your
project and inside of the app directory
is where we're going to
drag and drop that google services.json
file
so i just dragged it in and now in order
to do it saying move file over so i'll
say yes i do want to move this file over
and now we can see we have google
services.json
so now let's go back into the browser
and see what else we have to do
so now we have to add in the firebase
sdk or software development kit
into our android app so in the project
level build.gradle file we want to first
check if we have the google repository
and also
in the dependency section add class path
let's go back into the android
perspective
in gradle scripts the one which is in
the
root level we already have google up
here and we also already have google
down here we just need to add
the class path for google services tap
on sync now
now in the app level build.gradle file
we want to
add this line for the gms google
services plugin
so let's exit this build.gradle file and
open up this one
and here at the top is we're going to
add that copy that line and we have to
modify this to
match the format like that
and now we need to add the dependencies
for for whatever parts
of firebase that we want so firebase
actually has dozens of services
within it we're going to only really
need a couple of them
so i'm going to copy this line for the
firebase bill of materials
so we added that and now below this
we're going to add the dependencies for
whatever products that we care about
so let's open up this url
[Music]
there are two products in firebase that
we care about firestore
and storage so first off is
cloud firestore and make sure that
you're actually in the kotlin tab here
so you get the kotlin version of these
libraries
so we're gonna have to say
implementation
with this library and the second product
is cloud storage
and the nice thing with including this
build of material is that we no longer
need to specify the version on each
firebase product that we're
adding in so let's tap on sync now now
we've pulled in firebase into our
project
let's go back into our browser tap on
next here
and then tap on continued account
console and here we need to enable the
two firebase services that we're going
to integrate
into our project so let's start with
storage and then tap on get started
and tap on next choose a location which
is close to you so for me it's us
central tap on done
so now we have firebase storage set up
go into the rules tab
and by default read and write are only
possible
if there is a logged in user on the
client who's doing the request
and we don't have a notion of an account
or a logged in user in our app so i'm
just going to
set this equal to true
and then if you're publishing this app
of course you want to kind of be more
mindful about
who you're allowing to read and write
data into firebase storage but for our
purposes
this is going to be fine the other
product that we're going to use is cloud
firestore
so i'm going to create database and
we're going to start this in test mode
and test mode basically is
something similar to what we just did
it's saying that anyone can read and
write
to our firestore database as long as the
time stamp of the request is within a
month so for the next 30 days
anyone can view edit or delete data in
our database
and again we're going to put the same
location
perfect so now we have our two products
set up firestore
and storage i wanted to spend just a
couple minutes
describing how cloud storage and cloud
firestore
work together in order to allow the user
to create a custom memory game in our
application
this is the most critical part and most
complicated part of our application
so when the user creates a new memory
game they're going to pick various
images from their phone
and each of them will be stored inside
of cloud storage
and when we successfully upload
something into cloud storage we're going
to get back
a url which defines how we can retrieve
that image later on
so once we have a list of image urls for
each
photo that the user wants to attach into
their memory game
we're going to then take those list of
image urls and
upload that or push that to cloud
firestore along with the associated key
so for example in this case we have a
memory game called
corgi and corgi will have four unique
images
associated with that which is how we're
getting eight memory cards and that will
live in cloud firestore
and so now when another user somewhere
in the world wants to play
this game this corgi game they can type
that in to
the memory game app and we will pull
down
all the images from firestore associated
with corky and that'll be a list of four
different image urls
then that's how we'll be able to allow
the user to play this custom game called
corgi
so the complexity here is due to the
fact that
uploading these images is an
asynchronous operation
so there are two kinds of programming
one is asynchronous programming and the
other is synchronous programming
so most of the operations that you might
be familiar with are probably
synchronous
for example if you're doing two plus two
or any kind of simple arithmetic in
kotlin
or if you're combining strings those are
synchronous operations
in the sense that when you execute that
you can
expect a result immediately however what
we're dealing with here
is asynchronous which means that when we
execute the operation
we will not immediately find out whether
it succeeded or failed because it might
take
a longer amount of time image uploads
are a good example because images are
inherently quite data rich there's going
to be a lot of data
and uploading that over the internet
anything you do with the internet is
going to require more time
and so we're going to start the upload
process on all the images that the user
has picked out for their custom memory
game in this case where
the user has picked out the corgi game
and we're going to start uploading all
of them
into cloud storage and the tricky thing
is that the rate at which
these images get uploaded it's not in
our control so for that first image
it might be halfway done uploading the
second image might be totally not
uploading
and so on for the third and fourth we
might have a different rate of uploading
so the question now becomes how can we
figure out
when all of these operations have
succeeded so we can record
the image url corresponding to each
image that we've uploaded
and the way we'll do this is by getting
notified
when each image has successfully been
uploaded so as soon as the image reaches
cloud
storage we will get a corresponding
download url for that image and we'll
track how many download urls have we
received and the size of that list of
download image urls is equal to the
number of images that we're uploading
then we know we're done and so we're
going to continue this upload process
until we get to this state which means
that all the images have
finished uploading and now
we will have a list of image urls for
each
of the four corgi images that we have
we're going to combine that
with the custom game name which is
called corgi
and that is what we're going to send to
firestore that is what we're going to
implement
at least partially in this segment
so let's go back into android studio
the first thing we'll do is get a
reference to firebase storage and
virastor so at the very top of the file
call in the library that we included
makes it super easy let's say private
val
storage is equal to firebase dot storage
and then private val db which represents
firestore
[Music]
and so going back now to
where we have defined this image byte
array our goal is to
upload these into firebase storage the
way that works
is we're going to define a file path on
where this image should live in firebase
storage
and i want this file path to actually be
dependent on
the game name so if you ever wanted to
look at this
from the firebase console it'll be easy
to tell which images
belong together so custom
game name let's define this
as et gamename.txt
and then inside of that directory let's
specify the current time in milliseconds
dash the index
[Music]
and then this will be a jpeg file
based on the logic that we wrote in get
image by array and so the idea here is
that
if i have four images for example in the
corgi game then that'll be saved in
images slash corgi slash the current
time in milliseconds
dash zero one two three because there
are four images
this is a nice way to combine all the
images associated with one memory game
so now we have exactly what we need to
upload the
image to storage we have a file path and
the actual underlying data for this
image so we'll get a reference to the
location of where we want to save this
photo which will be
storage.reference.child with that file
path that we defined
and we'll put the image better data at
that location
all right so this is the operation which
will actually do this expensive work of
uploading the bytes representing the
image
to firebase storage and so instead of
getting the result of this
as some return value here
we will instead get a task which we have
to now wait for
until it succeeds or fails and so the
way we can
do this is we're going to say continue
with task
and what that means is this is an api
defined by firebase which says
this is a long running operation once it
concludes
then i want you to execute this code and
i want you
to also execute one more task so we're
going to define what that is
at the end but first the result of this
put bytes is a photo upload task
[Music]
and from here we can actually conclude
how many
bytes were uploaded just to get some
more info about what happened
so photo upload task dot result
and then if it's not null then we can
check this bytes transfer field
okay and then we have to end this block
this lambda block
with another task that's why we wrote
continue with task
and the task we're going to continue
with is once this photo has been
uploaded
now we want to get the corresponding
download url
photo reference dot download url
now you can see how the error went away
again getting this download url is going
to
give us a task and so now we have to
wait for the completion of that task
and that's an asynchronous operation so
in order to get notified of that we'll
call
add on complete listener
[Music]
and the parameter here will be the
result of this this operation that we
just triggered
so it'll be called download url task
[Music]
and the first thing we want to check is
did this operation succeed or not
so if download url task that
is if it didn't succeed then let's log
in error
and let's also show a toast telling the
user failed to upload image
if any of the images encountered an
error while uploading
let's set this as a boolean flag here
did encounter
error is equal to true so initially this
variable is going to be false
see about var don't encounter error is
equal to
false and then if we encountered an
error in uploading any of these
images then we're going to set that
equal to true
and if this happens we're going to
return do a premature return because
there's no point continuing
the important thing to realize is that
this add on complete list center will be
called
for every image which is uploaded and we
don't control the order in which these
are called right
and so if this particular image url
failed to upload then we'll go into this
if block but if some other image upload
failed then we wouldn't actually know
from here
and that's why we actually added this
boolean did encounter error
so if didn't counter error is true at
this point
that means that some other image has
failed to upload
and we again want to just return from
the add-on complete listener because
there's no point in continuing
otherwise we have been able to
successfully get a download url
so look inside the task look at the
result
and then cast it to a string and that
will give me a url
[Music]
and at this point now we want to make
note of the fact that this image has
successfully been uploaded
the way we'll do that is by keeping an
array of all the images that have been
uploaded so far
so we'll call this val uploaded
image url and that's equal to a mutable
list of
a string
[Music]
so down here we'll say uploaded
imageurls.add
and we'll pass in this download url now
let's put a log statement here
saying log.i with this tag and we'll say
finished
upload photo ui
so if we think back now to that diagram
how do we know when all the images have
been uploaded
turns out that's pretty easy right
because we're keeping a track of all of
the images that have
succeeded so far in this list all we
need to do is check the size
of that list so if the size of uploaded
image urls
is equal to the number of images that
the user has picked
then we know we're done so we'll say
handle
all images uploaded
so this is in some sense the success
callback for the images having been
uploaded
and from here in this method we're going
to pass in
the game name and the uploaded image
urls and this is exactly the information
that we need
if you remember to upload into firestore
so that's what we're gonna
handle later on uploading these two key
pieces of information into firestore
let's rename the parameters here to be
image urls and game name
[Music]
alright that was some pretty heavy logic
to think about
and implement let's test it out and see
if it works
so one thing i want to do is right now
we're launching the create activity with
the medium size board which requires me
to upload nine images that's too much
for me
i'm feeling lazy so i'm going to change
this to be
the easy board size rear on the app
so we only have to upload four images
now instead of nine
let's tap on one of these images and
let's grab
these three so now we have one more to
upload
so let's get this panda picture
okay so we still can't save the game
because we haven't given it
a name yet so let's say testing
[Music]
okay so now because we've added a valid
game name now the save button is enabled
and this
tapping the save button is what will
trigger these images to be
uploaded into firebase storage let's try
it
and before i hit save i'm going to open
up logcat
and as we upload images we should see
this log message
in the creativity for the number of
bytes that are uploaded
along with the progress the status of
how many images have been uploaded so
far let's let's
see if we can see those
okay awesome so we can see that we
have sporadically these log messages
let's filter for create activity because
that's all we really care about
so you can see how the original width
was a certain dimension and the scaled
width is
smaller because we're restricting the
height to be 250 db this is logic that
we wrote from before
now we have four images that we're
uploading so you can see we have four
we're seeing this uploaded bytes log
message four times which is great
and as we upload each image
we can see that the num uploaded goes up
each time
awesome so now to validate that this
properly worked
let's go back into the firebase console
and check um firebase storage we don't
expect anything to change in
firestore but in storage we should
hopefully have
one extra directory in storage
for this game and that's what we see
exactly here
so we have a directory called testing
and this should
have four images they're all prefixed by
the current time milliseconds followed
by the index which is what we have here
and if you look at the preview we're
seeing exactly what
we had uploaded which is really
promising
awesome that looks really good and you
can see kind of the rough size this is
around 14k
4k and about 2.7 k so this is
really pretty small so we're not
actually eating up
too much of the storage capacity in
firebase storage and it's also going to
make our app
feel a lot faster because we're
downloading less data as well and here's
what the image looks like
in the browser in the next segment we'll
finish off the missing link of taking
the image urls that we have
along with the custom game name and
uploading that to firestore
so we're now able to upload images into
storage but we haven't made the link yet
to
storing those image urls into firestore
so that's what i want to do
with you right now so if we open up
android studio
here's where we left it to do for given
this game name and the set of image urls
we now want to talk to firestore the way
we do this is
reference the db object that we have
defined above and we're going to put
this data into a document firestore
organizes
its data into collections and documents
so all
documents have to live in a collection
and one document
represents one entity in our
database so each memory game will be one
document and that document is gonna live
in a collection
which we're going to call games
inside of games will be a list of all
the custom games that people around the
world have created
and the parameter here is the path of
the document which is basically
the name of this document and it'll be
game name
and here we're going to set the data
associated with this game
and it'll be very simple all we really
want to do
is associate the image urls
to a key called images images
maps to image urls that is the data that
we're going to put inside the document
now let's get notified when this
operation succeeds
add-on complete listener and the
parameter of this lambda function will
be
a game creation task which indicates if
this succeeder failed
so if it didn't succeed game creation
task
is successful then let's log an error
[Music]
here
and if this happens we'll return early
otherwise we have succeeded so we can
they successfully
created game
game name and then in this
scenario let's show an alert dialog to
the user to communicate to them that
they've made the game and let's navigate
back now to the
main activity and play the game that
they just created
the user is only going to have one
option on this alert dialog which is to
tap on the ok button
and when they tap on the ok button we
want to
pass back to the main activity the game
name which has been created
so i'm going to create an empty intent
here and inside of this intent we are
going to
pass the game name they'll say put extra
extra game name
pass in the game name and then we'll say
set result
activity result okay
and result data and then finally once
we've set that data properly we'll
call finish
and we're going to show the seller
dialog so we should define
extra game name and this will be defined
inside of the constants
file
let's import it awesome so let's
try this now if we wrote our code
correctly that means
now we should not only upload images to
firebase storage but also
to firestore let's grab a couple images
here
okay so i added four and let's say
test two and tap on save
okay so after a couple seconds we can
see that we have this dialogue pop-up
where it says upload complete
let's play your game test two so that
seems promising let's see if it actually
worked instead of firestore so i go back
to
firestore
let's refresh this page and hopefully we
should see a new collection called games
now
yes and we do the document name is test2
which is the same
as the game name and inside of
the document is exactly one field called
images
and images is an array of strings and
each string represents
the url for the image so for example i
could copy this url
open it up and we see one of the images
that were uploaded
awesome this looks great so there's a
couple things i want to improve on here
first you might notice that
in save data firebase we are grabbing
the custom game name
based on the edit text and
we are unconditionally creating a new
game
with this data however if another user
in the world has already created a game
called test2 or testing or whatever it
might be then we're going to override
that data right so we're going to go
into firestore
and when we call dot set all the
previous data
that was inside of that document if
there was a previous document that will
be overwritten
and so what we actually want to do here
is
check if there already exists a
firestore document with this game
with this game name so right here the
intention of the code that we're going
to write
is to make a check on firestore and
ensure that we're not
overriding someone else's data
so the consequence of this logic is that
once i create a game of a certain name
for example
abc no one else in the world can create
a game with that same name abc
and that seems like a reasonable
decision to make
so here what we want to do is call
db.collection
i'm going to target the same collection
games and check do we have a document
with this game name
let's get it and that'll be how we
figure out whether
there is a game or not
so the result of this asynchronous
operation
in this callback is we get a document
and now we should just check
if the document is null and
if the if the document's not null and
the data of the document
is not null a game with this name
already exists in our database and so we
should not allow the user to create
another game with this name so i'll say
alertdialog.builder
set title to be name taken
set message
set positive button okay
no show
all right otherwise we want to then
execute all of this logic
that we had from before so i'm going to
actually put all that logic into a
separate function
called handle image
uploading
so let's create a function here and then
let's move
the parameter can be called game name
and let's move all of this logic
into that function
we renamed this parameter to be just
game name
awesome so we added an unsuccessful
center we should also
add a failure listener in case
for whatever reason we were not able to
retrieve this document
i don't really want to do anything too
meaningful here just log and error so we
can debug this if this ever happens
one more thing that i want to do is as
soon as the user taps on the
save button then we would like to
disable
the button
and the reason i want to add this button
dot
is enabled is equal to false as soon as
the user
starts making the network request is
because if the user spams the button
they would be attempting to create the
same game multiple times which doesn't
make sense
so as soon as they hit the save button
we wouldn't disable it so that no more
saves are triggered and if we get a
failure
then we would like to enable the button
again
so they can fix this issue and change
the name of the game and then they can
try saving it one more time and same
thing down here actually
if there was a failure for some unknown
reason like a network error
then we'll allow them to retry by
setting the
button to be enabled again let's try
that logic so we already have
a game that we just uploaded called
test2 so let me grab some images
call this test 2 and save it and
hopefully we should see an error
saying name taken perfect so we say name
taken a game already exists with this
name
name two please choose another okay and
now we have the
save button enabled again and we can try
changing it to be test three
and now hopefully this should work so
you can see while the image upload is
happening
the button is disabled so the upload is
complete
and now we can go back to firestore and
now we have test three here
with these four images that we uploaded
great the last thing i want to do in
this segment is i'd like to give the
user
some visual indication of how much
progress has been made
in uploading these different images
because this operation could take some
time especially if you have
the hard version of the memory game so
you have 24 cards or 12 unique images
uploading 12 images
could take a while and so it'll be nice
to provide the user some feedback on how
many
images have been uploaded already and
this turns out to be
fairly straightforward we can open up
activity create
and what i like to do is drag out a
horizontal progress bar
let's actually create some distance with
the save button
so i'm going to change this to be
150 dp from the bottom just so we can
create a bit more space
and now let's drag this out
and i want the save button to be
anchored to the top
of the progress bar so
get rid of that constraint and have this
be referred to the top there
and then the progress bar should be
match constraint for the width and then
we'll set the left constraint to be zero
from the left end of the screen and also
zero from the right end of the screen
well it shouldn't be zero dp it should
have some margin so let's have
maybe a margin of 16 from the left and
right end of the screen
and also 16 dp from the bottom
awesome that looks good so now as soon
as we hit the save button we want this
progress bar to show up
and that will be the visual indicator to
the user of how much
how many of the images have been saved
the one thing here
is that the progress bar should only
show up when this upload is in progress
so initially it should be not visible at
all and so for that
i'm going to go into the progress bar
and change the visibility to
gone and the other way you can do this
is if you
tap on that progress bar element and the
search for
visibility you can change it to gone
right here
cool let's give this progress bar an id
of
pb uploading copy the id because
we'll need that we'll need it for the
create activity
so let's go over here and
call it pb uploading and this is a
progress bar
all right let's define that right here
okay so now we have the progress bar as
soon as the upload starts
then we want to set the progress bar to
be visible
so where does that happen um in save
data firebase
what we're doing here is checking if the
game name
is unique so let's we're not going to
set the progress bar to be visible here
but as soon as we start uploading images
that's when we want to
set it equal to visible so i'll say
pbuploading.visibility is equal to
view.visible and here
if we encounter an error then we want to
set the visibility to be
gone again because we'll we'll we won't
make any progress at this point
view dot gone
and the interesting thing happens
whenever we have successfully uploaded
one image so right here is a success
case
we want to update the progress of the
progress bar
i'll say uploaded image urls dot size
divided by the total number of images
that we need to upload
so for example in the hard version of
the memory game we have 12 minutes to
upload and we might have uploaded
maybe six of them so far so that would
be 50 progress
so this progress requires
some integer but the integer should be
something between
0 and 100 and so right now this will
always be
0 because we're doing integer division
which will lead to truncation so in
order to get
something between 0 100 we're just going
to multiply by 100.
now the only thing left to do is let's
set the
prog the visibility of the progress bar
to be gone
when we're totally done with everything
so when we get to the
success case of all images uploaded and
we've uploaded this to firebase as well
right here we can set the view to gone
again
and actually i think it makes sense to
do this even before we check if the
game creation task is successful or not
because once we've gotten into here
we're no longer doing any network
operations so we should set the progress
bar to be gone
okay let's try it
so in order to make it a little bit more
visible let's go back
and choose the medium version
of the game just to have more images to
upload
and let's pick all six of these images
now we have three more to pick let's
pick the three over here
and then let's call this large test
tap on save awesome so we see a progress
bar and you can see how it's slowly
making progress
to upload each of those nine images so
that's pretty cool
and then we get the progress bar gets to
the very end then
shortly after that once firestore has
informed us that it has successfully
received the data
then we show this dialog upload complete
so tap on okay and then we go back to
the main activity
just to confirm this one more time now
we do have in firestore
this large test and it will have nine
images instead of four
because that's how many images we were
uploading
so now that we were done with the
creation flow
in the main activity that hack that we
had earlier
to automatically navigate there let's
remove that
after the creation activity is launched
from here
then we're calling start activity for
result
and so what we're going to do in the
next segment is figure out the result
passed back from the creativity
and if it's successful and we have a new
game created we would like the user to
play that custom game
now the user is able to create a brand
new customized
memory game our goal in this
segment is to be able to allow the user
to play that game
in the main activity in the main screen
and so we launched the creation flow
with the start activity for result
so we're going to capture the
result of whatever the tile activity has
done the creation activity
in the on activity result method
[Music]
what we'll do first is just check if the
request code
is equal to the request code that we
launched this with which is create
request code
and if the result code
is equal to result code activity dot
result okay
so if that's the case then let's
retrieve the custom
game game name
out of the data intent parameter
so get string extra extra game name and
so you'll remember
the reason i'm i'm doing this is because
in the create activity
as soon as the operation to create the
game is done then we
set the extra game name to be the newly
created game
so that's what we're retrieving right
here in the main activity
if for whatever reason the custom game
name is null then something has gone
wrong
and we'll just log that as an error
[Music]
and we'll return early otherwise we know
the custom game name is not null so we
have a valid game
i would like to create a method called
download game
with this custom game name
let's create this function
and the idea of this function is to
query firestore
retrieve the corresponding set of image
urls and use that to play the game of
memory
instead of our default icons so at the
top of the file
we need a reference to firestore similar
to what we had in the create activity
so right here i'll say private val
db is equal to firebase top firestore
and let's also capture the value of the
game being played so it'll be private
var game name
[Music]
is a nullable string and it's initially
going to be null because when you're
playing a default game with just the
icons that we've predefined
there is no game name um it's only set
when the user is playing either their
own custom game or a custom game made by
someone else
so back in the download game method
we're going to query firestore
inside of the game's collection that's
where everything lives and we're going
to try and retrieve
the document called game name
let's get it and then that operation
might take some time this is
asynchronous call
so we're going to add a on success
listener
and we also will need to add a failure
listener and then this
this is easy but it's going to kind of
log this so we can
keep track of um
what happened
[Music]
okay so in the success case here is
where we're doing something interesting
we are going to get back a document
which has
one field in that document which is
called images and that will
correspond to a list of image urls a
list of string
and so that mapping of taking this
document which is what we're going to
get back here
and turning that into a kotlin data
class is something that firestar will
help us with so we'll say document.2
object
and we want to map this to a data class
that we're going to define
and i'm going to call it user image
list
like that so let's define this now
create class
and i want to put it into the
models directory that we already have
and this is going to be a data class
there's no body the only thing that we
really need to define here
is the field name of what this entity or
this data class will hold and there's
only one which is called images
so it'll be val images
and it's going to be a list of string
and it's going to be nullable and the
reason it's nullable is because firebase
mandates that every time you do this
kind of mapping
between a document you get back from
firestore and into a
data class it needs to have a default
value and so it's going to have a
default value of null
and one other thing that we should do is
annotate this
field with a property property name
i'll say property name
images this is how firebase will know
that
here's the key called images which is
defined over here
and it maps to this attribute which is a
list of string
cool so back in my activity now that
we've done this document.2 object
we will get back a val
user image list
if user image list is null or if the
images attribute of user image list is
null then something has gone wrong
and the shorthand for this is to do user
image list question mark dot
images so i want to log this as an error
invalid custom game
data from firestore
let's also put a snack bar here to just
message this out to the user
cl root
and then this is the error case so where
it's going to return
early here okay so if you've gotten past
this return statement
if you've gotten past this if block that
means that we have found
a game successfully so now we want to
reset up
the recyclerview with this custom data
so first off let's compute how many
cards are in our memory game
so val num cards is equal to user
imagelist.psy.images.size
times two so for example if there are
four images
inside of our image list that means that
the total number of cards should be
eight because we're making pairs
so now given that we have eight cards we
can now figure out
the board size the board size has to be
one of the enums that we've defined over
here it has to be either
easy medium or hard and what we know is
we know the value so we need to figure
out
how to take the value 24 and map that to
hard 18 maps to medium and eight maps to
easy
and the way we're going to do this is by
adding a companion object
inside of the enum called fun
get by value and just as the name
implies
based on the value that we pass in here
which is an integer
we're going to return one of these three
enums
so we'll say the body of this function
is going to be a one-line function we're
going to look at all the values
of this enum through this method called
values and we're going to find the first
one
among this
such that the number of cards in that
enum is equal to
the value
so this is a nice cute one-liner and the
reason this is valuable is now
we can set the property board size from
before
based on the number of cards so the
number of cards
and we can also set the game name to be
the game name defined here
this actually leads to some naming
conflict so i'm going to rename
this local variable to be custom game
name
and now it won't be ambiguous that i'm
trying to set
the property game name to equal the
local variable game name
okay and so now there's a complaint here
board size value of requires a string
but the actual is a
int oh it should be get by value
okay the next thing we want to do
is call this method setup board
but setup board has to actually now have
information about
what is a list of image urls right and
we're not actually saving that inside of
any property so let's add that as a
property now
i'm going to add one more private member
variable
called
custom game images and this is going to
be a list of
string and it'll be nullable because in
the default case
this list will always be empty right it
doesn't make sense to have
a list of image urls when we're just
playing with the default icons
so we're going to set this equal
right here when we query firestore and
get back
a list of images so this is going to be
equal to user
image list dot images
so now let's go into setup board and
actually start using
the custom game images variable that we
have
along with the game name
the objective here is we want to prefer
using the custom image list if it's
there
over the icons because that means that
the user is explicitly intending to play
this custom game
so the change we're gonna make is we're
gonna pass in the
custom game images as a constructor
parameter on the memory game
so let's add this as a parameter
[Music]
hit refactor and we're going to call
this custom images
[Music]
and here the memory cards that our
memory game is going to contain
will depend on whether custom images is
set or not
so if it's not set so if custom images
is equal to null that means we'll just
do what we've already been doing
which is to look at the default icon
list grab some icons out of those
and create memory cards out of them
however if
custom images is not null then the
memory cards
should instead be using the image urls
as the underlying picture of that memory
card
so we're going to say val randomized
images
is equal to custom images and we're
going to get
two copies of each image in that list
then randomize it and now
the list of memory cards is going to
equal
randomizedimages.map
and we're going to create a new memory
card for each of these
so one thing you'll notice here is
there's an issue which is that
this randomized images here is a list of
string
that makes sense because each element is
an image url which is a string
but memory card if you remember the
first parameter
is a identifier which represents the
image resource
the drawable resource and we don't have
that in the
case of a custom game so what we're
going to do is add
one more constructor parameter called
image url
and this is going to be of type string
and this will be optional
because in the case of the default game
this is it doesn't make sense to have
anything here
having the default value of null here we
can create memory cards identically to
how they were created before
but now if we wanted to we can also
specify an image url and that's exactly
what we're going to do
over here and pass in it for the second
parameter
now the first parameter we need to pass
in some identifier
which is an integer and so in order to
do that we now need to figure out how
can we take an image url
and turn it into a unique integer and
the easy way of doing this is by using
a method called hashcode this is
something that's defined on every single
object including strings
and the idea is that for two different
strings the probability of them having
the same hashcode
is very very small it's almost
impossible
and so by having it.hashcode we're just
basically
taking the string whatever it might be
and translating that into an integer and
that will be
our new memory card it's almost done in
the memory
board adapter now
this is where we are actually rendering
that drawable
from the default list of icons that
happens right here
we're saying image button dot set image
resource so if the card is face up
we are setting the image resource to be
that drawable resource
otherwise the background however in this
case we don't want to do this
right in the case of a custom game image
if there is
a image url on the memory card we would
instead of setting an image resource we
want to actually download that image
from that url
so in order to download an image and
show it into
an image view there are a couple
libraries on android which makes this
super easy and the one that we're going
to use is called picasa so if you use
google for
android picasa github you'll come to
this page and what
you should do is scroll down to the
download section and copy this line
implementation now add this
line into the build.gradle which is
located in the app module
tap on sync now
and going back into memory board adapter
now we can use picaso
to render the image at that image url
inside of this image button
so the logic will be if the memory card
is face up
[Music]
then we should check is the
image url of this memory card not equal
to null
if it's not null that means that there
is a valid custom image
at this memory card that we should be
rendering instead of a
resource identifier so we'll call
picasso
so we're going to import that dot get
and we're going to load in the image url
into the image button that's how simple
it is to use picasso
otherwise we're going to do what we had
before
which is image button dot set image
resource
on the memory card identifier and this
is going to be one of the icons that we
had created
if the memory card is face down then
we're going to go into this else branch
and then we're going to do we're going
to set the
launcher background so just just that
all right so we just wrote a lot of code
hopefully it all makes sense let's try
it out try it out
i'm going to run the app and we're going
to create a new game
and save it and then when we save it
we're going to come back into the main
activity and hopefully we'll be able to
play this new custom game that we
created so i'm going to
create a custom game make it easy so we
don't have too many images to upload
and let's
do this the four images here
and say play game as the name
tap on save
all right so we can see the progress bar
upload complete so now
we should be going back into main
activity and main activity
should at that point fetch all these
image urls from firestore and display
them
in the memory game let's see if it works
so now it all looks identical to what
was there before because right now
everything is face down
but when we flip over a card you can see
hey it actually downloads this image
that we had which is amazing
i got lucky with a match on the first
one
okay so this is working so we're able to
download the images
from this custom game and we can play
the game like normal
so the logic of figuring out which two
images are the same
works because the hash code of these
images
if they're the same image should be the
same so that logic
is all identical to what we had from
before
awesome so we won and we have the same
logic there from before
all right so to finish off there are two
really quick things i want to do
back in main activity so first off
in the setup board method one thing that
would be nice
is as soon as we call setup board if
there is a custom game which the user is
playing
we should change the title of this
to be the name of the game rather than
the default my memory so in this case
we should hopefully have seen play
underscore game
as a title instead of my memory and we
can do that pretty easily
just by saying support action bar dot
title
and set this equal to game name
and the game name might be null so in
the case that it is null
then we want to set it equal to the name
of the app
it's r dot string.app name that's one
thing i wanted to do
second thing i wanted to do is a bug fix
so right now one thing you'll notice is
that
if we create a new default game of a
different size
we're going to trigger this method show
new size dialogue and so
if the user is playing a particular game
and they
create a medium sized game then we're
going to call setup board
but the issue is that setup board might
still be using
the cached data the save data inside of
game name and custom game images and so
basically the the key thing here is we
need to reset
these values every time the user
goes back to a default game so
in the show new size dialog right before
we set up the board let's just
null out the game name and also
the custom game images should also be
null
awesome huge progress in this video what
i want to do
next is allow the user to enter in the
game name that they want to play using a
menu option
but right now the only way to play a
custom game is by creating it and then
we immediately will play it
back in the main activity so what i want
to do here
is add one more menu option for
downloading
an arbitrary custom game so to do that
we're going to
add a menu option so open up
menu main and we're going to add in one
more
final menu item
let's give this a title of
download custom game
and the id can be mi
download it's a menu item download
and similar to the other two above it
we're gonna
have show as actually never so we always
want this to be in the overflow menu
let's copy the id go back into main
activity
and register a listener for when that
menu item gets tapped so r
dot id dot mi download
and in this case we would like to call
this method show download dialog
download dialog and then return true
okay let's define this method
so i'm going to put this below the
functions that were overriding
and then i misspelled downloads let me
fix that
[Music]
so this download dialog is going to be
simple all it is is
the ability for the user to enter in
through an edit text
the name of the game that they want to
download so i'm going to use the layout
inflator to
inflate that view which has the edit
text so i'll take
layout inflator from this
inflate r.layout.dialog
download board
null is a second parameter this is going
to be
a view that we're going to call board
download view
and the idea is going to be we're going
to call that same method that we have
show alert dialog the title will be
fetch memory game and the view
is going to be the board download view
that we are about to define
and the third parameter is what should
happen when the user taps on ok
so it'll be view dot on click listener
and what we want to do here is grab the
value
text of the game
name
so let's first define the dialog
download board layout
the root element here can be a
constraint layout that's fine the only
view that we need in our constraint
layout will be in edit text
and before modifying individual
attributes of the edit text directly
here
one thing to notice is that we're going
to be using many of the same exact
attributes as the edit text that we
showed
in the creation flow and so i'm going to
open up activity create
and we have edit text here i'm going to
go ahead and copy all of that
go into the code tab of the dialog
download board and copy over
that same edit text we'll have to add in
the app namespace declaration many of
the attributes for example the allowable
input digits
number of max lines input type important
for autofill all of that should be
identical
in this edit text in the edit text in
the creation flow but there are a few
modifications we'll want to make
let's change the margin bottom to be
margin top and make it 16 dp
let's update the hint to say enter game
name so the user knows what to do with
this edit text
and the constraint bottom doesn't make
sense anymore because there is no btn
save
so i'm just going to say constraint top
to top of parent which makes it flush
with the alert dialog top
finally let's update the id to be et
download game
now we can grab the edit text from that
board download view
find view by id with the specified id
and now the game to download will be the
text attribute of this
edit text that will say
etdownloadgame.txt.2string.trim
and now we can call our method download
game with this game to download
string okay let's try it
run the app and now we should hopefully
see one more menu option
next we do download custom game and i am
going to
try out the larger game that we had
tried from before large
test tap on ok
so this is good it's promising because i
do remember that we had
made the large underscore test game a
medium-sized game which means there are
18 cards or nine images that we added
and yeah you can see that this is indeed
the
images that we had uploaded so one thing
you'll notice is that there's a little
bit of a delay
the very first time that we download
that particular image
it takes a couple hundred milliseconds
or maybe even one second
and then every subsequent time that we
download that same image for example the
golden gate bridge
subsequent times that we display the
image is much faster because picasso is
caching that image once we've downloaded
it once subsequent times are much much
faster to load
so that's one optimization i'd like to
do which is in the download game method
as soon as we're successfully found the
game
one thing we should do is pre-fetch all
the images with with picasso
and this makes this is actually it's
pretty straightforward i'm just going to
say for image url
in user image list dot images
and i'm going to say picasso
dot get and i'm going to just load the
image url
dot fetch and what this dot fetch is
doing is saying hey let's go ahead and
even though we're not displaying this
into an imageview right away go ahead
and
download it and fetch it so it's saved
in the picasso cache
and one other thing i'd like to do here
as well actually just
show a snack bar to indicate to the user
that they're playing this custom game
[Music]
let's try it
so we have a couple games we've uploaded
so far large test play game test tune
test three let's try
maybe test three and one other thing to
look for is that the
title of the screen in the action bar
should also update
appropriately let me say this test three
okay so we are playing test three we got
the snack bar and now you can see
that the image images are loading much
faster which is a great sign
now we can play the game like a normal
game of memory one bug you'll notice at
the top
is the activity action bar title hasn't
been updated appropriately
so let's debug that if we go into the
setup board
method that's where we set the title and
so it relies on game name and the bug
here is that the game name should be set
before calling the setup board method
so by doing that now that bug should be
fixed let's try it one more time
so let's try downloading a game called
game two
oh there is no game two what did we call
it
test two
awesome and so you can see how now the
title of this activity has changed to be
test two and got that snack bar
and we should hopefully be playing this
new custom game and now it feels so much
snappier so that's great
one last optimization i want to make on
the picasso side which is that
there's still no way to avoid the fact
that we might have to
spend a little bit of time downloading
the image the very first time
and so when that happens in the memory
board adapter
there's a nice functionality in picasso
to load a placeholder image
while the image url is being fetched
and so i would like to add that as well
i'll say r.drawable.ic
image and so we're going to define one
more vector
asset which will be kind of the
placeholder image a silhouette of
an image like a black and white image so
let's go into project
go into the resources and let's create a
new
vector asset in the drawable directory
called image
so we'll call this ic image and
yeah let's leave it as color gray and
then finish
okay so this error went away and let's
see
if we can actually see the placeholder
image so if we're really quick
after we download a game then we might
be able to see it briefly
i'll say large test
[Music]
yeah and then you might have briefly
seen the very first image i flipped over
we were able to see that placeholder
image and all the subsequent images are
much
faster to load because we're doing that
prefetch operation
so that's a really good sign it's a much
better experience now
before moving on to the next segment
which is focused on design
and style improvement there's one more
small improvement i want to make here
which is that if we have this snack bar
show up
right now there's no way to actually
dismiss it and it's not that hard to
make the snack bar dismissible and give
the user more control over the ui
simply by going into the activity main
and right now the root element is
a constraint layout if we instead change
that to be
a coordinator layout then any snack bar
can then be dismissed by the user so let
me do that
coordinator layout
and then we're going to add a bunch of
these properties
in the coordinator layout
so copy this put it at the end
and then i'm going to hit command option
l in order to fix the indentation
and we also need the layout width and
height on the constraint layout of
course
and this id of cl root we're actually
going to apply that
onto the coordinator layout so
everything else is identical because the
only time we
were referencing cl group is as the
anchor for the snack bar
and by making the anchor for the snack
bar coordinator layout now the user
should be able to
dismiss the snack bar with more control
let's try it okay it looks like we
are crashing and i think i know why yeah
the
reason is because there's a class cast
exception if you go back into main
activity
you'll remember at the top of the file
right now we're
defining cl root as a constraint layout
but this should actually be a
coordinator layout
and here clru is finding you by id and
that's fine so
now let's try it hopefully we won't
crash
so we are able to boot up properly and
if i trigger
the snack bar now you can see how i was
able to dismiss it
in the next part i want to do some low
hanging design improvements with all of
you
and then we'll be done with all of the
functionality and design for the whole
app
in this segment i want to make a couple
of very easy but powerful
improvements in the app the first one is
not so much an improvement but avoiding
an issue in the app which is if you
rotate the screen
so you can see that whenever you don't
hit the screen in android the activity
is destroyed and recreated
and we are not doing a great job with
managing
the space here our app isn't very smart
around
when the phone is wider than it is
taller the number of
columns in the memory grid should be
larger but right now we're still
assuming this portrait mode where we
will always have
more rows than we will have columns and
so we have two options
one is we could actually properly
address this
and that would require some logic inside
of the memory board adapter and figuring
out
how much space to allocate in the width
and height
the other option is to do the lazy thing
which is not allow
the user to change the mode of these
activities
to be in landscape and that's what we're
going to end up doing so if we open up
android manifest
we have two activities in our app
creativity and main activity
and we're going to update the
screen orientation attribute to be
portrait and that's it that's the only
valid option
[Music]
and by adding this line into the android
manifest file
even if the screen is rotated even if
the user rotates their phone
then android won't actually go through
the activity lifecycle we're not going
to be destroying the activity
and so we're still looking at the same
portrait mode ui even in landscape
the two-line solution that we came up
with here to lock the orientation in
portrait
is definitely the lazy solution but i
would argue that this is actually
a reasonable trade-off to make our job
as engineers is about efficiency
and so you have to make the decision
about how much value are you delivering
to users by implementing
proper landscape mode in the app versus
how much engineering time or developer
time would that take and can you use
your time better elsewhere
you can definitely implement this if you
want to learn more but the key takeaway
here
is thinking about what problem are you
trying to solve the
second improvement i want to make is i
want to add a little bit more
festivity when the user wins the game so
right now let me quickly see if i can
win the game
so we just have this snack bar show up
u1 congratulations
i'd also like to have something a bit
more festive and in particular i want to
have some confetti pop up
and this turns out to be really easy
because we can use a library which does
this for us
so if you go to your browser and just
google for android confetti library
you'll come up with
this github repository and this is the
one that we're going to end up using
so i'll show you how to use it but right
now all you need to do is copy over this
line
to add this into your build.gradle file
which is located in the app module
tap on sync now so we can pull this
library into our project
and now let's go into main activity and
let's figure out where do we actually
detect that we won the game
so as soon as we flip over a card that's
the only time when we have the potential
to win the game and we have this
snack bar that we show up right now so
right here is where i'd like to now
show this confetti and it turns out that
we can do this with
literally one line of code i'm going to
invoke a static method in the library
i'll say common confetti
import this and we're going to call this
method raining confetti the first
parameter here
is the container that'll be the parent
element on which the confetti should be
falling so
call cl root and then the next parameter
is the
colors that you want the confetti to be
so i'll say
int array of and we're just going to
pass in some
colors that are already defined for us
by the android system
and you can kind of pick whatever you
like here's the ones i picked
yellow green and
magenta in order to actually launch
the confetti we call this method one
shot
and that's it let's try it and see how
it looks
amazing so you can see how this confetti
is falling and there's some like
particle physics
inside of the library some map so that
we have
some particles some confetti falling
quickly some falling slowly and they
also will drift side to side
so it's a really nice simple way to make
the app more fun
the next thing i'd like to do is update
the color scheme of the app
and there's definitely no right answer
here you can be creative and pick
whatever color you like
but what i recommend most people do is
go to color.adobe.com
and this is a really nice way to pick
out a color palette you can kind of
take this drag it around and figure out
what color scheme you like
and if you don't like uh this one which
by default is analogous you can pick out
one more like monochromatic triad
complementary or whatever you want and
this
gives you a nice working set of colors
which we can then use
to update our android app we have a
couple different colors like the status
bar color
this action bar color and this
background color of the linear layout
so those are the colors that i want to
update so let's open up the
colors.xml file i'm going to add three
more colors here
first we'll define green dark then we'll
have one more called green darkest
and then a third one called green blue
and you can pick whatever colors you
want for this like we talked about
here's what i picked for green dark
green darkest is a darker shade of green
dark
and then finally green blue is a teal
and you can see a preview on the left
hand side
now we have to make use of these newly
defined colors
and we'll do that in themes.xml we'll
define color primary to be
green dark we'll define color primary
variant to be
green darkest and notice on line 13 the
status bar color
is the color primary variant and finally
in the secondary brand color
category we'll update both the color
secondary and color secondary variant
to be green blue one more thing i'd like
to call out
dark mode is all the rage these days and
so android studio actually has
a separate file themes.xml located
inside of values
night and so if the app or phone
supports dark mode
then the colors inside of the
values-night themes file will be read
instead of the one that we defined
just something to keep in mind if you're
into that sort of thing
let's try our app with these new colors
and if we've done our job correctly we
should no longer see this purple color
at the top we should instead be seeing
the palette of green we picked out so we
have a green action bar
a darker green for the status bar and
the bottom the blue green
the final design improvement i'd like to
make is to change the
view of the memory card when it's face
down this green grid because it just
feels like our app is still under
construction
and instead use some custom image for
the
default state so you're welcome to pick
whatever image you want for this
i'm going to open up the drawable
directory and the image that i found i
downloaded from the internet
is this picture of bamboo so everyone
loves pandas
therefore everyone should love bamboo
i'm going to drag this bamboo.png file
into the drawable directory now let's
reference this bamboo.png file
inside of the memoryboard adapter which
is where we are
setting the icon when a memory card is
facedown
so right here on line 65 is where we're
setting the image resource
if the card is face down and we're going
to set this equal to bamboo
so let's run the app and see what this
looks like
perfect so you can see how now we have
the bamboo background and we can play
the game like normal
all right okay so let's try just for
good measure let's
play the whole game and go through the
creation flow as well so i'm going to
create a brand new game
i'm going to call i'm going to have this
be easy i'm going to call this
corgi and of course i can't save the
game right now because i haven't added
the images
but let's add our wonderful images of
the corgi
so i have four images of a corgi here
and then let's tap on save
perfect it looks like it succeeded tap
on okay and now immediately we go back
into the main activity
and we can see that the title has
changed to be corgi and hopefully we
should be able to play our game now
yay and you can see that okay we have
this confetti following we have a snack
bar
we are recording the number of moves
properly and
we have this green text showing that we
are 100 done
and we found all the pairs we can replay
the game
and this works because we're still
holding on to the
image url list of all these corgi images
and we can play like normal
i can also choose a different size so i
can pick like a medium sized board
and here notice that we are reverting
the title back to my memory because this
is now playing a default game with
default icons
and we're also updating the text at the
bottom and so now we're playing with the
default icons
rather than the image urls coming from a
user
this looks really quite good if you've
also gotten this far in the game
i would love to hear from you drop a
comment and let me know
i'll leave you with some extension ideas
the really nice thing about the memory
game
is that there are so many creative and
fun ways to
extend the functionality of what we've
built together
so one idea i had was simply to add
different board sizes so right now we
have three enums representing the
different dimensions of the board
easy medium and hard we could simply add
a couple more enums
for different configurations another
idea i had
was to introduce user authentication and
if you allow the user to log in then you
have this
really nice ability to be able to see
all of the custom
games all the custom boards that that
logged in user has made
so you have this notion of history or
profile
for that user and finally there could be
a lot of interesting work around
discovery of other people's boards so we
could imagine
there are hundreds of different custom
boards created and i want to see which
ones are popular and i could also
enjoy playing other people's games so if
you do end up doing any of these
i'd love to see it drop a link to the
published app or the github repository
and we can
celebrate your app in the next segment
we're going to prepare our app for
release
so i'll walk through a checklist with
you about what i typically do before i
publish any app on the google play store
if you've gotten this far i really hope
you're planning on publishing what
you've built
the app that we have is really full
featured and really fun to play with
and there's a social aspect as well so
in this segment
i want to walk through a checklist of
some of the things i always think about
before publishing any app
onto the play store first is the app
icon
so if we tap on the home button and then
swipe up to open up the app launcher
screen
you can see the app we have here is the
default one so of course before
publishing
we'll want to have a unique app icon for
our app
my memory you can design the app icon
yourself or use a design agency or
something like fiverr in order to get a
high quality app icon
here's what i came up with it's a grid
of nine squares of different colors
to indicate that there's some sort of
pairing or matching going on
the main thing to keep in mind with app
icon is that you want it to be square
and you want to avoid text or anything
which is too detailed
in the image because users won't have
that much time
or the ability to see your app icon in
hi-res so you want to be very
obvious at a glance what your app is
so once you have something you're happy
with then go into the drawable directory
go to new and tap on image asset
and this asset studio will help us to
create
all the different icons that we need
depending on the
kind of phone that you have so i'm going
to tap on path and we're going to choose
that icon that we had just created
so now you can see a preview of how this
icon might look so depending on the kind
of phone if you have a samsung phone or
a
google pixel or something else the icon
might look a little different and this
is all the different ways
that it might be rendered so i'm pretty
happy with that
so we're going to leave it the layer
name as i see launcher foreground
tap on next and this is basically just
saying that we're going to overwrite
the default ic launcher let's tap on
finish
great and so now if we run the app let's
see
if we actually have the app icon
properly reflected so i'm going to exit
the app and go here and you can see
it does indeed show our new app icon
awesome
so that's one thing you want to do the
other is enabling
minification and proguard if you open up
the build.gradle file i can show you
what i'm talking about
you should have a section in your app
level build.gradle file
for release and build types and what
this is saying is
what are the steps of the build process
that you want to run
on the release build when you actually
publish your app you're going to be
publishing a release build what we've
been doing so far
is a debug build by default android
studio is going to have this minify
enabled
option as false in release builds it's
important that you turn this on to true
and the reason you want to do this is
because it will shrink the size of your
app so an app which might be 20
megabytes
with minifi enabled it'll be much
smaller than 20 megabytes
in my experience the size savings can be
more than 50 percent
and the reason app size is important is
because users often don't have that much
space
on their phone and also people may not
have good connectivity
and so a large app may deter them from
downloading it
from google play and just to demystify
this a little bit
when you enable minification what's
happening is there's something called
proguard and proguard will basically
look at all the libraries that your
project is including
and strip out methods that are not being
used or not being referenced
and through that it's a it's a really
nice way to get rid of code and
resources which are not
are not referenced and reduce the size
of your application or of the apk which
is generated at the end of the day
and that's downloaded onto the device
you do want to be a little bit careful
with proguard
because it's stripping out methods
sometimes it's a little bit over
eager and it may strip out something
which you actually do need in your
project and so you want to make sure
that you test out your release build
properly
and make sure there are no issues that
come up in the release build
that don't happen on the debug build for
example one thing i discovered
after turning on minification is that i
previously didn't have
in the user image list i didn't have
this property name
images in the data class and this
actually worked fine in the debug build
but when making a release build this
caused a crash and so i needed to
explicitly add
property name images in order for
firestore to be able to construct the
user image list
correctly tip number three is
if you want to understand better what
your users are doing in the app once you
publish it
i'd recommend that you integrate
firebase analytics
and so there's a guide here you can
google for but this is a way
for you to understand how many users are
opening up the app
how many users are taking a particular
action in the app and you can define
what that action might be so that's an
option that we're not going to walk
through here but
if you really want more detailed
analytics about
how people are behaving then this is a
good way to do that
one other thing that you want to do for
sure is test your app on different
phones and different api versions so
right now we've only tested our app
on this pixel 2 phone which is running
api 29
but you want to make sure that you test
your phone on a tablet if you want to
target tablets
you want to test it on the most recent
api version api 30 for example
you want to also go back five or six
years and test
your app out on a phone which is running
api
maybe 24 25 and make sure that
everything works
look in our build.gradle and you can see
the minimum sdk version is 21.
so you probably want to test a phone
running api 21 as well
we've only been testing our app right
now on emulator it probably is also
worth testing on a physical phone if you
have one
just because that will give you a
genuine experience of how real users
will interact with your app
emulators are great for testing out your
phone on very old devices or devices
that are physically hard to get a hold
of
but it's definitely worthwhile to try
out the app at least once
on a physical phone and the final tip i
have
is to translate your strings
right now we have a bunch of text that
we show to the users those are called
strings
and these strings are all written in
english for example here snackbar.move
we say invalid move and this is
bad practice because if the user is
changing the locale
of their phone to let's say spanish or
hindi or some other language
then we would want to be able to
translate this text
into that language and the way you do
this typically
is by having all the user facing strings
belong in this strings
xml file so right now we literally only
have one string which is
the app name but if you wanted to
internationalize your app and have it be
popular in
countries that are not english speaking
then what you'll want to do
is move all of these strings out into
the xml file
and then reference the strings.xml file
instead of having hardcoded text
and once you have all the strings in an
xml file like this
you can create an additional version of
the strings xml
for each language so you'll have one
strings xml for english
one for spanish one for french one for
hindi and so on so
there are probably a bunch of other
things that you could do to optimize
your release
and make sure it's successful this is a
very quick list of what i typically
think about when i publish
if you have other ideas or other things
on your checklist i'd love to hear
what you do let me know in the comments
how you think about it
at this point not only are we done with
the debug version of the app but also
the release version which is the
optimized version of our app
for publishing in the next segment we'll
upload our release app to google play
and create a listing for our app on the
play store
the goal for this part is to publish our
app on google play which is the dominant
android app ecosystem run by google
once we do this we can easily share our
app with friends and family which will
be really
fun and you can point to your app in
your resume or your app portfolio which
will help you in landing a job
google makes it relatively quick and
easy to
become a developer on their platform
compared to the apple app store which is
the app store for iphones and ipads and
there are two
big differences between google and app
apple here one is that it's way cheaper
to become a developer for google
it's a one-time fee of 25 to become a
google developer
compare that to apple which is 99 every
year
so that actually adds up really quickly
on the apple side whereas google is much
much cheaper
and the second reason that it's easier
to become a developer with google
is because the review process for
publishing an android app is much
lighter compared to apple
the google's process for reviewing our
app is largely automated which means
that the turnaround time is a lot faster
whereas apple will have a real-life
human manually check your app
and you might be rejected if your app is
deemed low quality or if it's doing
something
that apple doesn't like and so there's
been a lot of articles talking about
the pros and cons of each approach i
would say that the
average app quality on apple is going to
be higher because
they actually do reject quite a few apps
and they have a higher quality standard
but the diversity of apps on google play
is way higher with more than two million
published android apps and that's
because google accepts most of the apps
that are submitted to the play store
and the other impact of the automated
review system of google is that the
iteration speed
is a lot faster so with apple you might
have to wait
more than a week in order to get a
review and get your update published
but with google as you make improvements
those updates will go out faster
to the end user so we're going to spend
a lot of time
in the google play console in order to
create a new app and
update it with all the information but
before we do that there are
two pieces of prep work that i want to
do one in the emulator and one in
android studio
so first in the emulator this is where i
want to spend a few minutes just taking
some screenshots
of the app so the way you can do that is
ctrl s on a pc
or command s on a mac so we can just
take one of the home screen
why don't we take a screenshot with some
of the cards flipped over
let me try and get a match
well that looks good let's do one more
screenshot here maybe we can do a
different size
for a couple
and then maybe we can also include a
couple of the creation flow
and then finally maybe we can show folks
that they can download a custom game
okay awesome so those have now been
saved by default they're going to be
safe at the desktop
we're going to use those later when we
create our google play listing
so the next thing we'll do is open up
android studio and we're going to create
a release bundle from android studio and
that'll be what we upload to google play
if you go into the menu go to build and
tap on generate signed bundler apk
you have two options here an under app
bundle or an apk
so the android app bundle is recommended
because it's a newer file format that
google was pushing
and you can kind of think of it like a
zip file which contains
other files inside of it and in
particular it contains the compiled code
for your project
plus the resources and it lets google
play
create an optimized apk that users will
get on their device and so depending on
the kind of device
and the screen size and other things
google play will optimize
what code and resources needs to be
downloaded by that user and that results
in a smaller download size
so i want to pick android app bundle tap
on next and here we need to
create a key store and this is
a key store is basically a way that
google can validate the authenticity of
the developer
and so i'm going to choose the location
as the desktop
then i'll give this a name of keystore
dot chaos and then provide a password
and make sure you keep the summary
secure because if you lose this
you're going to have to create a brand
new app on google play rather than
updating your existing app
[Music]
same thing with the key you need a alias
we'll leave as the default key 0
use some password here
and then for the certificate i'm just
going to put my first and last name
and that's all we need for now
of course my passwords don't match let
me try this one more time
[Music]
okay seems like that worked tap on
remember password just so that
as we make changes in the future we
don't have to keep typing all this
information again
tap on next and then we want a release
version of the app
and so our app is fairly small so this
building of the release
app shouldn't take too long but if you
have a larger app this can certainly
take
several minutes all right so it looks
like we are able to generate the signed
bundle so i'm going to locate it
shows up over here and so you can see
here the aab file is 2.5 megabyte and
that's pretty good
it's a pretty small app and keep in mind
that this is an upper bound of the size
because the aab
is essentially a zip file and google
play will optimize
what apk generates for the user's device
so 2.5
megabytes is an upper bound on the size
of our apk
so what i have over here are all the
screenshots that we took so i'm going to
drag over the aab file into this
directory
and this is now everything we need in
order to create a
good google play listing so let's go
back now
to google chrome and go to the google
play console
i'm going to create a new app we'll
update this with a bit more detail later
on but just for now i'm going to call it
my memory
the default language is english us it's
going to be a game this is a
free app and then we're going to agree
to
a couple of policies and then tap on
create app
all right so google play here will walk
you through a bunch of different
questions and policy things that you
need to answer
and then after we do that then we're
going to upload our aab
the first is app access in our case
everything is available without special
access there's no such thing as logging
into our app
let's go back to the dashboard let's go
to ads we have no ads
content rating we need to fill out a
questionnaire i'll put in my email
address
our app is a game tap on next
all right the only thing that we have to
answer yesterday is actually this
question because the app does natively
allow users to exchange content
through sharing images that's if you
create a new memory board and someone
downloads that that's one way for users
to interact with each other so we tap
answer yes on that question but we can
answer no
on all of these
all right and then if you look through
you can see the rating that we
got in our app it looks like as expected
our app is
pretty friendly for everyone submit
let's go back now and see what else have
we not done all right so the next is the
privacy policy so every app has to have
a privacy policy and typically what i
recommend for this is if you don't want
to go through the hassle of setting up
website
just create a google doc which describes
the privacy policy and paste that in
i put that together over here and i can
actually link this if you want to
copy a similar privacy policy i
basically took this as a template from
some other app
it just describes the app and how we're
using some google services
so i'm going to copy this make sure it's
accessible to anyone with the link
paste that in click tap save
and then target audience we are going to
target anyone 13 and up
if you target people less than 13 there
are some other compliance rules that i
want to deal with
around targeting kids tap on next
and then our store listing will not
intentionally unintentionally appeal to
children
so tap on no there and then we're done
with this section
tap save all right and then
it seems like we have one more section
here is our app a news app and there's
no
all right so we have completed all the
questions about
the app content that's great so now
let's
actually go into the store listing i'm
going to the main store listing
and there's a couple things that are
required anything with asterisks is
required
regarding metadata about our app like
things that are describing
our app so i have a
note over here where i spent some time
putting together a
name description and full description
[Music]
so i'm putting in a name of my memory
image matching game
and the app name is actually really
really important because that's how
google play will figure out when to
surface your app for
search queries on google play and i have
a friend
alex who wrote a really good article
about how to think about naming your app
and it really comes down to two things
number one
know what people are searching for in
order to try and find your app
and number two put those words that
people are searching for in the title of
your app
and so i'm basically guessing that if
people want to download our app they're
going to be searching for
things like memory or image matching or
game and that's what i've put
in the title one thing you can do is if
you're publishing the same app
i'd love for all of us to be able to
find each other and try out the
different versions of the app that
people have built
so just put your name here
[Music]
so that way anyone else who's looking
for this particular app they can find it
by they can find out who made it by
looking at the last section of the title
and this this topic of seo or search
engine optimization is a huge topic
you can read a lot about how do you game
that and how do you make sure that your
app
gets the best chance of being surfaced
i'll leave a link to alex's article if
you want to learn more about that
so short description is um something
which is 80 characters or less
so what i did for that is this
a free customizable memory game on
android match pairs images
and then the full description can be a
little bit more uh robust and long
so i'm not going to read it all right
now but basically what i'm describing is
that this is a
totally free open source app it's
customizable memory game um
there are no ads and i'm documenting
some of the main features here
all right so the next thing is graphics
there are two required graphics one
which is the app icon and one which is a
feature graphic so the app icon has to
be 512 by 512.
um these pixels are exact so it can't be
even one pixel off and then the feature
graphic has to be 1024x500
and so what i recommend you do for this
is open up a program like sketch
let me show you what i've done here are
all of the assets that
we use for the memory game here's the
app icon which is 512x512
and for example if you wanted to create
the feature graphic you can
insert a rectangle in sketch and then
update the dimensions as appropriate so
we'll want it to be 1024 wide
and 500 tall and then you can kind of
play with this however you want change
the color add in some shapes add in some
images
and then once you're happy with what you
have then you can export both the icon
and the feature graphic
let's come back into the google play
console and we will drag and drop
our feature graphic and app icon so for
the feature graphic
let me show you what i put together
so just a picture of the corgi just
because that's kind of the
main custom game that we've created uh
with
this same color scheme of the app
drag that over and then while that's
uploading i'm going to also upload the
app icon
and so what i did for that is what you
already saw
just this grid of squares
[Music]
and so now both the app icon and feature
graphic are updated
and finally we get to the phone
screenshots so i'm going to go back
to this directory where we have all the
screenshots
and drag those out
okay that looks good and you can have up
to eight screenshots minimum of two
and there are some really fancy things
that you can do to make these look a
little bit better
like having some sort of colored
background or combining two of the
screenshots into a continuous
shot but we're going to leave it simple
for now
we are going to ignore the tablet
screenshot so let's basically
reuse the phone screenshots same thing
with the 10 inch
and we don't have a video for now tap on
save
so now we have the basics for our main
store listing
we're going to go into the release
section go into production here's where
we're going to create
a new release and just one thing i'll
mention we're not going to deal with it
currently but
there is an option here for testing your
app before you do a broad production
rollout so you have open testing as an
option or closed testing
and also internal testing these are
basically various options to
allow you to test out your app with a
trusted set of users
in your company or with friends and
family or just have an open beta program
prior to releasing it publicly we're not
going to deal with any of that just to
keep it simple
so i'm just going to go into production
track and create a new release
and we're going to use app signed by
google tap on continue
and then we're going to drag and drop
our aab or android app bundle
so i'm going over here drag dragging
that
the release name can be initial release
[Music]
and then release notes i'm just going to
leave as the default tap on save
all right that looks good one thing that
we'll need to do is specify which
countries
we want to release our app to so tap on
this add countries and regions and i'm
going to go ahead and select all of them
so we're going to add all 151 countries
then we're going to go back to releases
tap on edit and then go to reviewed
release
it looks like we have some errors all
right so it says that our app can't be
published yet complete the
steps listed in the dashboard so let's
see what did we miss in the dashboard
so we have to specify an app category
let's do that we are a game
and in particular we are a puzzle game
let's just quickly add a tag called
memory
[Music]
apply that now we'll leave our email
address and opt
into external marketing and hit save so
now let's go back into the production
release section
go into releases tap on edit
and let's see if we are able to properly
release this now okay amazing
so we have set up our store listing
properly we've done all the
questionnaires all the
policy agreements and we can see the
internet bundle and then we'll hit this
button for start rollout to production
so the review process might take a
little bit longer
now because of chronovirus and and the
lack of
staff but my experience historically has
been that still
with a simple app like this we should be
able to get a review
and have it approved within two or three
days
hey everyone welcome back the my memory
app that we submitted to google play
just got approved into the store so what
i want to do
in this segment is walk through the
google play listing
along with doing a quick concept review
of everything we've talked about to get
to this point
and then we will celebrate so here's the
store listing it's pretty much what
you'd expect the app
icon and the title are what we submitted
into the google play console
it shows the developer name here along
with on the right side more
apps by that developer so i have two
other apps live in the play store which
you can see here
we have the category of the app
screenshots description
and then when we get reviews those will
show up over here
this section what's new is about release
notes for subsequent versions of the app
you can leave a message
to users about what has changed and the
magical thing about software
is that it's so easy to change to
iterate and to improve
so i actually already made one
improvement in the app which is i added
a couple more colors
into the dark theme so that the app will
render better
if your phone is using dark mode so i
would encourage you not to view
publishing your app into the play store
as an ending point but instead a
starting point where now you can make
a bunch more improvements in terms of
features or designs
at the bottom we have additional
information for example when was the app
updated
how large is the app 2.3 megabytes how
many installs does it have
and also requires android 5.0 and up and
this is coming from
the minimum api version of 21 in our app
and it tells
users how recent does their android
phone have to be in order to download
this app
so the really cool thing about having
this app published is now we can take
the url
and share that with anyone in the world
and they can very easily
download this application my memory on
their phone and tablet and play
one of the core features that we built
into the app is the ability to create
your own custom memory game
using photos from your phone so you're
already familiar with the
corgi game that we used during the video
walkthrough for
the creation flow i also have one called
bitmoji which is my bitmoji character
doing different things
and then one more you can try out is the
board game i created called rao which is
pictures of me is doing various
activities
so if you also have a funny or creative
custom
memory game with your own photos drop a
comment and i would love to play it out
one more note on the topic of publishing
from the time that i submitted the app
until it got approved by google it was
about three days i'm not really sure
what the standard is given cova 19
if you had a much shorter review time or
much longer i'd love to also hear from
you
the last thing i want to do in this
segment is a review of everything we've
covered
so there's a ton of really fundamental
concepts that we've
learned that you can now apply to
whatever else you want to build
we created a brand new android studio
project so we started from scratch
and then the main ui of our application
is built on top of the recycler view
and the interesting thing is that the
contents of that recycler view will be
dynamically measured based on the screen
width and height
we also started thinking about how do we
use models to represent the different
objects in the memory game the memory
card and memory game
and this is going toward the direction
of app architecture so we didn't
explicitly
talk about different kinds of app
architectures but basically app
architecture means how do you organize
your code and so by using
the recyclerview and using the memory
card
memory game we have already better idea
of how to partition up the logic so it's
easier to debug and extend our
application
and we also integrated with two firebase
services storage
and firestore for the creation flow and
finally we were able to publish our app
into google play and we talked about
some of the best practices there
so here is the same picture cloud
representation that i showed you in the
very beginning
of all the different things we learned
we made a brand new android studio
project so you're
definitely familiar with android studio
now we talked about how to
create vector icons and use that as a
default memory card
we talked about views on android and how
they have content padding and then
margins live outside the view and we
take that into account
when creating the view width and height
the recycler view is the core component
which is
responsible for displaying that grid of
memory cards we talked about how there's
a layout manager which
puts things in the grid the adapter
which is responsible for binding
a view in the recycler view to the
underlying data set
which is a list of memory cards we also
are uploading images to cloud storage
and we're using cloud firestore as
the database which is associating the
game name to a list of image urls
and then finally like we just talked
about we are now live
in the google play store so the result
of all that work
is this where we are able to create
a custom game with these very cute
corgis
we won the game and we have confetti
falling and we have that message at the
bottom
and furthermore anyone in the world can
now
download our app from the play store and
play play this game as well
throughout the whole process if you have
any questions or feedback
i would love to hear from you i'm on
twitter youtube and linkedin
and instagram at rponde1234 so i'd love
to connect with you
and as you share the progress of what
you're building
or if you have a really funny or cute
custom memory game
um please use this hashtag mymemory in
social media that way we can all see
the progress we are all making and
giving encouragement or feedback
to people all right that's all i had for
this project
i hope you had as much fun building out
this project as i had teaching it
if you want to help me out hit that like
button and subscribe so you can become
part of this
learning community until next time i
hope you're all staying safe
and i will see you in the next one bye